PUBLIC SAFETY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE QUORUM NOW THAT
WE HAVE WHAT ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE AISLE
HERE WILL MAKE SURE THAT.
WE TAKE THE QUORUM VOTE ALL OF
US ARE IN OTHER COMMITTEES RIGHT
NOW SO EVEN THOUGH YOU THINK YOU
SEE ISSUE REALLY DON'T.
.
BUT WILL DO THE BEST WE CAN TO
GET THROUGH THE AGENDA TODAY
NONE OF THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
GOING TO BE TAKING A FULL VOTE
AT THIS TIME. SO MOST OF THE
RIVER INFORMATION AND
CLARIFICATION BUT.
BUT WE DO WANT TO HAVE THE
HEARINGS AND THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE THAT ARE HERE AND SO IF
YOU SEE SOME OF US MOVING IN AND
OUT IT'S FOR THAT REASON EVEN.
I'M IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
IN THE NEXT
FORTY MINUTES A SO SO UP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY.
MATT MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY THANK YOU WE ARE CURRENTLY
WAITING FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO BE HERE I UNDERSTAND WERE
DOWN TO ONE MINUTE NOW.
THAT HE SHOULD BE COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR WE'VE GOTTEN A
COUNT DOWN FROM THREE HAD TO
WHEN I STARTED TALKING SIZE SOON
I'VE CONSUMED AT LEAST A MINUTE
OF TIME.
BUT WE WILL WANT TO HAVE INCOME
AND TO MAKE A STATEMENT WERE
HONORED THAT HE WANTS TO COME TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEETINGS AND HAS
EVERY YEAR. BECAUSE HE'S BEEN AG
TO COME AND TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEFORE SO.
WE WILL WAIT FOR HIM TO COME
WITH IS BECAUSE HE'S THE
BEGINNING OF OUR AGENDA SO THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
.
WE'RE HAPPY HAPPY TO HAVE WITH
US THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. HUBBY A
PER SE ARE WITH US INTO SOMEONE
IMPORTANT WAS COME THROUGH THE
DOOR BECAUSE THEY OPEN THE DOOR
FOR HIM. AND SO THAT MADE ME
REALIZE IT WAS TIME FOR ME TO
SIT UP STRAIGHT NECK LIKE A GOOD
CITIZEN.
.
I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
MEETING OF THE.
A PUBLIC SAFETY SUB A BUDGET SUB
FIVE I INDICATED TO THE. MEMBERS
HERE WE.
WE'VE WE'VE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
BUT ALSO THAT I AM VERY PLEASED
BECAUSE YOU CHAIR AND.
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LETTING ME BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY IN TO TESTIFY SPECIAL
THANKS ESPECIALLY TO EVERY. FOR
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE.
ALONG WITH THE GOVERNOR AND YOUR
STE TEAMS.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO BRING
STABILITY IMBALANCE IT TO THE
STATE AND TO OUR BUDGET.
I WANTED TO BE HERE PERSONALLY
BECAUSE THIS PROCESS IS CRITICAL
TO THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH THE
CAR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
I WANT TO GIVE A FEW HIGHLIGHTS
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE TESTED.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SOME FOURTEEN
HUNDRED BREAK IT'S ACTUALLY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN TO BE PRECISE. RAPE
GIFTS AT THROUGH OUR RAPID DNA
SERVICES PROGRAM.
HOW OR THE RATS PROGRAM IS IT'S
KNOWN? WE ARE UP TO DATE. IN
THOSE RAPE KITS INTESTINE OF
THEM AND WE HAVE NO BACKLOG.
WE RECOVERED THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE FIREARMS
FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE PROHIBITED
FROM OWNING THEM.
WE SEE WE SECURITY A ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
SETTLEMENT AGAINST ROYAL BANK OF
SCOTLAND. FOR MISLEADING CALPERS
AND CASTERS AYE MORTGAGE BACKED
SECURITIES.
WE DEFENDED THE FACT ACT.
IN THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT.
AND WE STOPPED OIL GIANT VALERO
FROM MAKING AN ACQUISITION THAT
COULD HAVE LED TO HIGHER GAS
PRICES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WE ALSO BROUGHT DOWN AND SECURED
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AGAINST A
SEX TRAFFICKING RING OPERATING
OUT OF TULARE COUNTY.
SELLING YOUNG WOMEN MANY UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN FOR SEX.
THIS WOULD BE A COMMENDABLE
EFFORT UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT REMEMBER. WE
ARE LIVING IN EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES.
SINCE JULY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ALONE WE HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
TIME DEFENDING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AGAINST FEDERAL
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS FROM
WASHINGTON DC.
IT'S A TESTAMENT TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF OUR DEPARTMENT. AS WELL
AS THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHO HELPED US WITH THE RESOURCES
WE REQUESTED. THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO RESPOND QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TO THREATS FROM
WASHINGTON DC.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU ALL OF YOU AT
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT PARTNERSHIP WILL BE
CRITICAL AS WE ADDRESS NEW AND.
I THINK.
ONGOING CHALLENGES FOR OUR
STATE.
EXAMPLES BUMP IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE MAINTAIN THE CRIME
FIGHTING EXCELLENCE OF THE
BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES.
FINGERPRINTING DNA TESTING AND
CRIME SOLVING TECHNIQUES SERBIA
ES
MAKE IT A GREAT TV SERIES.
EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT BFS IS
WORK AND ITS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OUR REAL.
THE BUREAU IS SUPPORTED BY THE
DNA ID FUND.
WHICH IS EXPERIENCING DECLINING
REVENUES.
THE REVENUE GAP NOW STANDS AT
TWENTY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
ON TOP OF THAT THE BUREAU HAS
BEEN FORCED TO POSTPONE OR FORGO
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT UPGRADES AND
MAINTENANCE.
IF WE WANT BUREAU TO CONTINUE.
AS THE RELIABLE GO TO CRIME
SOLVER THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RELIES ON.
TO PROSECUTE CRIMINALS.
WE NEED TO GET SERIOUS AND
CLOSER REVENUE GAP.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENT TO POSSESS TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FORENSIC TOOLS.
TO COMBAT TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CRIMES.
SECOND OUR DIVISION A LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS IN THE THICK OF
THE FIGHT AGAINST WHITE COLLAR
CRIME.
CYBERCRIME. AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
BUT MODERN TECHNOLOGY HAS MADE
IT EASIER FOR CRIMINALS TO
COMMIT THESE OFFENSES.
AND THE THREAT CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED.
WE NEED TO KEEP PACE.
I'D ACTUALLY SAY WE NEED TO
OUTPACE
TODAY'S MARTIN CRIMINALS.
THAT WON'T BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT A
SIX POINT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO HELP CALIFORNIA
PUT UP THE FIGHT.
AND PUT MORE CYBER CRIMINALS
BEHIND BARS.
IN ADDITION OUR CALIFORNIA
JUSTICE INFORMATION SYSTEMS
DIVISION WHAT WE CALL SEE JUST
IS WORKING TO PREVENT CYBER
ATTACKS AGAINST THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ITSELF.
AND AGAINST LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE NEED THREE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS INVESTMENT TO PROTECT
THE SECURITY OF TENS OF MILLIONS
OF SENSITIVE RECORDS AROUND THE
STATE.
THESE ARE THE CHALLENGES THAT
REQUIRE A CONTINUED FOCUS AND
COLLABORATION. ESPECIALLY AS OUR
DEPARTMENT FACES A NUMBER OF
UNFUNDED MANDATES.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE A MAJOR
RESPONSIBILITY IMPLEMENT AB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR. SIGNED INTO
LAW LAST YEAR. WHICH ESTABLISH A
TIER BASED SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM.
WE ADVISE THE LEGISLATURE. LAST
YEAR AS THIS BILL WAS GOING TO
THE PROCESS THAT IT WOULD COST.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
THIS NEW SYSTEM NEXT YEAR ALONE.
EVEN WITH HIGHER COSTS OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN THIS CASE
FAILURE IS NOT AN OPTION WHEN IT
COMES TO DETERMINING WHEN AND
WHETHER SOMEONE CONVICTED OF A
SEX OFFENSE
MUST REMAIN ON A LIST OF
REGISTERED SEX OFFENDERS.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS SIMPLY NOT
BUILT FOR THE HUGE VOLUME OF
DATA NECESSARY TO MAKE HEARING
POSSIBLE.
WITHOUT THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING WE IDENTIFIED IN ORDER
TO MAKE THIS CHANGE IN THE LAW
POSSIBLE.
I CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY THAT WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO MEET THIS
LEGISLATION'S REQUIREMENT TO PUT
EACH OF THE STATE'S NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRANTS. INTO ONE
OF THREE TIERS BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ADDITIONALLY WE FACE ANOTHER ONE
MILLION DOLLAR UNFUNDED MANDATE
ASSOCIATED WITH THREE BILLS FOR
WHICH.
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS
RECEIVED NO FUNDING.
WE REQUESTED ADDITIONAL POSITION
AND EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO IMPLEMENT AB ELEVEN FIFTEEN.
A BILL RELATED TO CONVICTIONS
AND EXPUNGEMENT.
WE NEED THOSE FUNDS TO ENSURE
THAT INCREASES IN REQUEST FOR
DISMISSALS.
OUR PROCESS WITHIN THE REUIRED
NINETY K..
TIMEFRAME.
BUT WE WERE DENIED THE REQUEST
FOR FUNDING AND POSITION.
SO I WANT TO ALERT YOU TO THE
CHALLENGE THE STATE WILL FACE IN
IMPLEMENTING A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
TODAY.
WE REQUESTED AN ADDITIONAL TO
POSITIONS AND THREE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ENFORCE AB FOR FIFTY.
THE IMMIGRANT WORKER PROTECTION
ACT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
COMPLAINTS THAT THREE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
WHAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
COMPLAINTS.
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND
CONDUCTS CIVIL PROSECUTIONS.
BUT WE WERE DENIED.
ONCE AGAIN WITHOUT THE RESOURCES
I CANNOT REPORT TO YOU THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS THE
ABILITY TO MEET THESE NEW
DEMANDS. GIVEN THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXISTING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WE REQUESTED ADDITIONAL FIVE
POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ENFORCE S. B. THREE NINETY
THREE.
A BILL RELATED TO SEALING
CRIMINAL RECORDS.
WE NEED THOSE FUNDS TO ENSURE
THAT CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION IS PROPERLY
MAINTAINED AND UPDATED.
BUT WE WERE DENIED. ITS HARD TO
SEE HOW WE ACCOMPLISH THIS NEW
WORK WITHOUT THE PERSONNEL AND
RESOURCES TO DO IT. AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE DOING THIS WITH
MISTAKES.
IT'S TOO IMPORTANT FOR THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED AND IT'S TOO
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO DO IT
RIGHT.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE THAT WE
ARE DOING MUCH OF THIS WORK.
WITHOUT COMPETITIVE SALARIES.
TWO QUICK EXAMPLES.
OUR OUR SUPPORT STAFF AND OUR
PARALEGALS.
THEY MAKE ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT
LESS THAN WHAT IS PAID IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
I'D LET ME REPEAT THAT THEY
DON'T MAKE SICK LITTLE MAKE
SIXTY PERCENT OF WHAT YOU MAKE
ON THE PRIVATE SECTOR THEY MAKE
SIXTY PERCENT OF LESS.
THEM FOLKS OUT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR DOING THE SAME WORK.
OUR DIVISION A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS
THE FOLKS WHO PETRY WEAPONS FROM
BALANCE.
THE FOLKS WHO DO THE THE CHECK
ON EVIDENCE FORENSICS AND OTHER
WHITES.
ARE THERE PAID APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN PERCENT BELOW OTHER
STATE AND A LOCAL POLICE
OFFICER.
IT IS TOUGH TO COMPETE.
TO GET THE BEST.
AND OUR HIGH SALARIES FOR SENIOR
TURNS.
WELL THEIR COMPARABLE TO WHAT A
LAW SCHOOL GRADUATE FROM A
PRESTIGIOUS LAW SCHOOL. COULD
MAKE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IN HIS OUR FIRST YEAR.
OUT OF LAW SCHOOL.
AS A LAWYER.
THAT'S ONE HERE TO.
TELL YOU TODAY.
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE BUDGET
CHALLENGES WE FACE.
TO RECAP DUE TO THE REVENUE GAP
THEN UNFUNDED MANDATES ARE
DEPARTMENTS IS IN A DIRECT HOLE
OF THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ADDITION TO A WORKFORCE THAT
IS AND HAS BEEN UNDERPAID.
I'M ASKING THIS COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. MEMBERS OF MY OFFICE
ARE READY TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF TO IRON OUT FUNDING
DETAILS.
I KNOW IT IS NOT AN EASY REQUEST
BUT THERE IS NO MISSION MORE
IMPORTANT FOR US AND TO PROTECT
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE TOGETHER.
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT TOGETHER WE
CAN FIND A WAY TO MEET WITH THE
CHALLENGES AHEAD.
AND REMAIN THE STATE THAT LEADS
THE NATION
WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR OF SUMMIT
ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FOR MANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO THE COMMITTEE AYE I
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE HAD SEVERAL.
DISCUSSIONS ON.
I'M VERY OF TOPICS.
.
AND I WANNA ADD TO TO TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU KNOW I WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO TO ASK FOR BUT
WE. WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT UP
CANNABIS AND THE OUR INABILITY
TO CRACKDOWN ON THE BLACK MARKET
AND ILLEGAL BACK MORE STATEWIDE.
AND I BELIEVE USED TO BE A A
BUREAU OF NARCOTICS ENFORCEMENT
THAT WAS HERE DURING DISCOURSE
* ADMINISTRATION.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT BUDGET GOT
SLASHED IN HALF AND EVENTUALLY.
pUNDERSTANDING THAT THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN. ON THE
FEDERAL TO THE STATE AND LOCAL I
WAS COORDINATED BUDDHIST GROUP
INNATE DID.
SUPERB JOB AT THAT GOING AFTER
THEY'D BE THE COORDINATOR
TRAFFICKING HERE AND IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND.
WOULD LOVE TO TRY TO RECREATE
THAT.
LOVE TO HAVE IT PAID FOR.
BY THE INDUSTRY ITSELF BECAUSE I
THINK IS IN THEIR BEST INTEREST.
TO CRACKDOWN ON THE BLACK
MARKET BECAUSE THEY GO MOBILE TO
THRIVE.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE LOOKING AT
MAYBE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
SIZE.
IF WE COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO DO THAT ESPECIALLY IF WE
COULD BE AS COST NEUTRAL AS
POSSIBLE.
WOULD THAT BE SOMETHING YOU
LIKE FOR US TO LOOK INTO ARE
FROM PEOPLE LIKE TO. TO SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER WE
ARE HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
WITH YOU AND OTHERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NEED TO HAVE
A STATEWIDE ENFORCEMENT ARM THAT
WILL HANDLE CANNABIS.
THEIR IS NO WAY THAT THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WILL BE
A TO HANDLE THIS BY THEMSELVES
THERE HAS TO BE COORDINATION.
I ACTUALLY THINK THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE'S DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
COULD.
HANDLE THIS.
WITH.
.
AND NOT JUST GREAT EXPERIENCE
BUT AS YOU MENTION WE DID VERY
WELL WHEN WE DID HAVE.
THE BUREAU THAT DEALT WITH
NARCOTICS.
AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT WE'D
MOVED QUICKLY.
THAT WE WOULD UNDER RESOURCE THE
NEED TO GET THIS DONE RIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE US A US.
A SMALL WINDOW BEFORE.
THIS BEGINS TO OVERWHELM.
STATE AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
BECAUSE.
CANNABIS AS AN INDUSTRIES IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW.
WHETHER IT GROWS.
AS A ABOVE THE TABLE MARKET OR
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
IS UP TO US
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL BE
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THE FOLKS
WANT TO DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
AREN'T BURDENED BY TRYING TO
COMPETE WITH THOSE WHO WANT TO
DO IT THE WRONG WAY.
TWO NOTE LOVE TO WORK WITH ME ON
AT ANY.
TING YOU NEED OUR HELP ON IT TO
TO FURTHER THAT I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE.
WOULD BE.
RECEPTIVE TO THAT I KNOW YOU
HAVE A. BIG THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AFTER RIGHT NOW
BUT.
.
THIS IS
WE THOMAS.
SIX BILLION DOLLAR. ENTERPRISE
IT IT'S WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE I SUCCESSFUL TOO BECAUSE
THE MONIES THAT COME IN FROM
THAT.
COOK ULTIMATELY HELP FUND OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AND THEN I. I KNOW YOU.
DID YOU DO JG JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN LOOKING INTO POLICE
SHOOTINGS.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF.
YOU'VE THOUGHT ABOUT ANY DO YOU
NEED ANY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES DO
YOU NEED. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT.
.
AS WE MOVE FOR.
YOUR DEPARTMENT DOING MORE OF
AN. OBVIOUS HIS COMMITTEE WOULD
MAKE SURE. YOU WELL RESOURCE.
TO DO THAT HOPEFULLY WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO DOWN THIS ROAD AGAIN.
WE HOPE WE NEVER HAVE TO HAVE
ANOTHER SHOOTING OF THIS
MAGNITUDE.
BUT IF WE DO I THINK IS REALLY
GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC.
AND THEIR TRUST
AND IT ALL PHASES OF GOVERNMENT
THAT WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT ARE.
TECH INCOME IN.
AND PARTICULAR OBJECTIVE LOOK
AT WHAT. WAS DONE WHAT HAPPENED
BUT MORE PORTABLE WE NEED TO DO
IN THE FUTURE
WHICH I THINK A LOT OF TIMES
THAT THAT'S MISSING SO. I KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE WORKING ON
SOMETHING SACRAMENTO NOW BUT HOW
DO YOU SEE THE DEPARTMENT MOVING
FORWARD. NOW ONLY WITH WITH THAT
PARTICULAR INCIDENT BUT WHAT
RESOURCES.
AND MONEY YOU NEED NOW I'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS I REMEMBER.
YOU READ OFF ALL THESE BABIES.
AND I REMEMBER AYING ISIS IT
WHERE YOU'RE SITTING AT A.
AS IT THAT'S KIND OF A
BUREAUCRAT AND THESE ELECTED
OFFICIALS WILL COME OVER ALL
THESE LAWS BUT IT WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH MONEY ENOUGH RESOURCES.
SOMETIMES WOULD NOT WELL THOUGHT
OUT IDEA BUT I HAD TO IMPLEMENT.
AND IF IT FAILED I GOT BLAMED
FOR TIME.
I'M GOING.
BACKWARDS OR I'M GOING FORWARD
AND ACTUALLY ASKING WOULD YOU
NEED HOW YOU DO IT BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY. PUT SOMETHING ON MORE
THINGS ON YOUR PLATE.
THEN THE REST THAT'S ALL FAIR
AND.
.
THE ONE THING I I COMMITTEE YOU
IS THAT I I MONEY I'M GONNA TRY
TO BE AS STRAIGHT SHOOTERS I
CAN'T ON THIS HIGH HAVING SAT
WHERE YOU ARE. AND LISTENING TO
EXECUTIVES TRY TO TELL ME WHAT
THEY NEEDED IT IN THEIR AGENCIES
BUDGET.
I LEARNED WHAT HAPPENED WHEN AN
AGENCY FEELS SOMEWHAT
CONSTRAINED TO SAY.
WHAT IT REALLY NEEDS BECAUSE OF
THE?
THE BUDGET THAT THEY'RE HANDED
AND I WOULD I'D RATHER YOU KNOW
WHAT NOW IF I CAN MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN.
TO RESEARCH HAS I HAVE RATHER
THAN YOU HAVE HAVE BECOME
APPEARANCE IT WHAT HAPPENED WHY
DID YOU GET IT DONE.
AND I'VE LAID OUT TO USE SOME OF
THEUNFUNDED MANDATES THINGS
THAT I KNOW I CANNOT DO BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESEARCH ON
I WANTED ON THE RECORD NOW. SO
THERE'S NO QUESTION IF I COME
BACK WHY SAID HE DIDN'T HAPPEN
BUT IF YOU GIVE ME THE
RESOURCES.
THAT IS ON ME AND I WILL I
ACCEPT THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE WE MAKE IT HAPPEN.
OKAY AS FAR AS.
FUTURE INVESTIGATIONS. THAT LET
LET US PLAY THIS OUT AND SEE
WHERE IT GOES.
.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE.
DEPARTMENT THAT IS
.
FILLED TO THE BRIM WHEN IT COMES
TO WORK.
I DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S.
TO DO INVESTIGATIONS THE WAY
THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO.
.
BUT I DO KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING PROGRESS.
SOMETHING AS IMPORTANT AS
COMMUNITY TRUST WITH WITH THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE IN
SACRAMENTO.
THE CHIEF DANIEL HAHN REACHED
OUT CHIEF OF POLICE DE HAAN
REACH OUT TO ME AND I THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT.
TO WORK WITH AT THE DEPARTMENT
IN THIS CASE.
AND TRAIN PROVIDED INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT SOME INDEPENDENT EYES
LOOKING AT THE.
THOUGH INVESTIGATION.
ALONG WITH THE FACT THAT THE
CHIEF AND THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
CITY LEADERS WERE WILLING TO
AGREE THAT WE WOULD TAKE A
BROADER VIEW.
OF THE POLICING PRACTICES
A REVIEW OF THE PROTOCOLS THE
PROCEDURES THE POLICIES THE
TRAINING WHICH I THINK
ULTIMATELY GETS YOU TO THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THESE TYPES OF THE.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW THE QUESTION.
DO I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT. AND SAID THINK WITH
RESPECT TO CANNABIS THE.
A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING
THE STATE LOOKED AT IS THE THE
GOOSE THOSE LAYING GOLDEN EGGS
AND IT'S NOT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THAT
IS ALSO DRIVING THE BLACK
MARKET.
AND FOR WHATEVER RESOURCES THAT
I THINK IT'S IT'S LEGITIMATE FOR
YOU TO BE ASKING FOR RESOURCES
FOR THAT.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE CHARGING THAT
INDUSTRY SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THE LEGITIMATE
INDUSTRY THRIVES.
AND DOES WELL BECAUSE IT'S HERE
AND IT'S GOING TO BE HERE AND
THEN DO EVERYTHING WE CAN.
TO.
THIS INCENTIVIZE THE BLACK
MARKET.
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE.
REALLY THE NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
THAT ARE GOING TO COME OUT OF
THE.
BUT ALSO ON THE LINE IN AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY. YOU'RE WISE TO
BE HERE AND AND ENGAGE WITH US
AND BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT.
WHAT?
CHALLENGES THAT DAY YOU ARE
FACING AND THERE'S A IN THAT
VEIN THERE'S A BILL THAT'S
COMING THROUGH MY COMMITTEE.
ON A NEW BUREAU OR A NOTION OF A
NEW BUREAU FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE
THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN WORKING
THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY.
QUITE.
ABED AND LATELY REALLY STARTING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
IS A LANGUAGE AND A PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS VERY WELL
UNDERSTOOD HERE BUT IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA MOVING FORWARD.
SO THAT THAT BILL IS MOVING
THROUGH POLICY COMMITTEE BUT
IT'S REALLY A BUDGET QUESTION.
AND I KNOW THERE'S A LETTER
HERE.
OUR COLLEAGUE MR GARCIA HAS HAS
PUT A LETTER FOR HOW DO YOU HOW
WOULD YOU SEE THAT ASSUMING THAT
WE FUNDED AND I'M CERTAINLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE. OF.
THAT THAT EFFORT ENSURING THAT
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ENSURE DID. MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
THE WORST IMPACTED BY SOME THE
BARBELL DEGRADATION
OR BEING WERE.
TREATED RESPECTFULLY AND AND
TREATED APPROPRIATELY AS WE TRY
AND FORCE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
THAT'S SORT OF HOW I WOULD SEE
HOW HOW WOULD YOU SEE THAT
COMING TOGETHER.
I I THINK FOR THE LONGEST TIME
WE'VE LOOKED AT.
THE ISSUE OF PROTECTING ARM
FIREMAN.
AND HANDLING.
OUR ACTIONS
IN DEFENSE OF CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER. A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT AS
A GLOBAL ISSUE.
AND I OFTENTIMES WHAT WE
DISCOUNT IN THAT PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT.
THEIR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HIT.
FIRST.
AND HARDEST.
AND ARE LEAST EQUIPPED.
TO ADDRESS THE ILLS THAT COME
FROM DEGRADATION OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
AND UNLESS WE DO SOMETHING FOR
THESE COMMITTEES EARLY.
WE MISSED THE BOAT.
BECAUSE.
THESE ARE COMMUNITIES HAD BEEN
LIVING WITH. LEAD TAINTED HOMES
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND FOR THEM THE NEED IS
IMMEDIATE THESE ARE HOMES THAT
HAVE.
.
BEEN IN NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
RIGHT NEXT TO ALL THE WHERE ALL
THE FREEWAYS HAVE BEEN BUILT.
AND HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
EMISSIONS FROM A.
TAILPIPES
FOR DECADES AND SO FOR THEM IT
IT'S REAL TO HAVE. A REDUCTION
IN THEM AND IN A MATTER OF.
.
POLLUTING EMISSIONS FROM
VEHICLES BUT THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN
SORT OF THE LAST TO COULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE SOLUTIONS THAT
WE COME UP WITH BECAUSE OUR
SOLUTIONS ARE VERY GLOBAL. WHERE
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES NEED A
DISTANCE IMMEDIATELY THAT'S WHY
AS AS ACCOMPLISH AS? OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SECTION HAS BEEN
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE
LEGAL SECTION.
AT IN DEALING WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT. I THOUGHT IT WAS
CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE A BUREAU
THAT WAS DEDICATED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
SO THAT THESE COMMUNITIES HAD
SOMEBODY ON THEIR SITE EARLY.
AND LOOKING AT THEIR PLIGHT NOW
VERSES IN THAT GLOBAL.
SOLUTION THAT WE COME UP WITH.
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA
FIND IS THAT WE'RE GONNA TAYLOR
ARE SOLUTIONS A LITTLE BIT MORE
CAREFULLY WHEN WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
WORRIED ABOUT TWENTY FIFTY WHEN
IT COMES TO POLLUTION THEY'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH THE CAR
EXHAUST LIVING NEXT THE FREEWAY
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN HAVING TO
WASTE INCINERATION PLANTS
LOCATED IN THEIR BACKYARD WHERE
THEY'VE HAD THE. EGGS AYE
BATTERY RECYCLING PLANT IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD ALL THE TIME. AND
THEY NEED NOW AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I THINK ENVIRONMENT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BUREAU
THAT WE WANT TO ESTABLISH. WILL
BE CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE WE HAD
THAT.
EXTRA THINKING GOING ON WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT.
DEALING WITH THE ENVIRONMENT IT
IF I COULD JUST ADD AS A MEMBER
JUST GROUP QUICKLY ON THE UP.
THE THE CANNABIS ISSUE.
IF I CAN SAY IS ON BEHALF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT?
THEY WE.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
YESTERDAY.
.
IT'S IT'S ALMOST IT'S ALMOST A
VICIOUS CYCLE.
THE SLOWER WE ACTED TO TRY TO
ATTACK THE.
UNDERGROUND PART OF THIS ECONOMY
ON CANNABIS.
THE LESS RESOURCE WE COLLECT.
IN LICENSE SEEN AND TAXATION SO
FORTH THE LESS RESEARCH WE HAVE
THE LESS MONEY WE HAVE TO SEND
OUT TO THE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LESS MONEY
THEY GET THE LESS ENFORCEMENT
THEY CAN DO THE LESS ENFORCEMENT
THEY DO THE MORE THE GUYS ARE
DOING LEGITIMATELY SAY WAIT A
MINUTE I'M BE UNDERCUT.
DRAMATICALLY BY THE GUYS ARE
DOING IT THE WRONG WAY. AND IT
BECOMES A VICIOUS CYCLE WHERE
ALMOST BECOMES BETTER TO DO IT
UNDERGROUND.
THEY DO IT ABOVE THE TAPE.
AND.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD
PRIORITIZE.
PUTTING MONEY IN THE HANDS OF
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
IT'S DONE RIGHT BECAUSE IF IT
STARTS TO BE DONE WRONG. IT'S
GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT TO ON
WINE THAT AND WE WILL RUE THE
DAY WHEN WE FOR GOT TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES TO MAKE THIS NEW
INDUSTRY. ESTABLISHES FOOTING.
IN THE RIGHT WAY AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT YOU GOT A WHOLE
BUNCH OF POLICE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS.
AND STATE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
.
OFFICERS LIKE ME ARE ARE HAVING
TO DO THIS WORK RIGHT NOW.
WITH NO NEW RESOURCES SO FAR TO
DEAL WITH THIS NEW ELEMENT
CALLED THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
AND WE BETTER GET A GRIP FAST
BECAUSE I I COULD EASILY SEE THE
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
SWING OF THE PENDULUM IN
OPPOSITE DIRECTIONS IT THIS IS
NOT WHAT WE EXPECTED.
THIS TO LOOK LIKE BUT TRY TO ON
WINE THAT.
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH MONEY
AND YOU WILL FIND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT SO GET IT DONE RIGHT.
GET IT DONE THE FIRST TIME HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NOT JUST THE RIGHT THING TO
DO WITH THE RIGHT WAY.
THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT.
AND I IN I DO AGREE WITHOUT THAT
I THINK SOME OF THE INITIAL
INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO MAKE WITH
REVENUES COMING IN IS FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL
AND. CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT AND
ENSURE WE WE CREATE A STRONG AND
HEALTHY LEGITIMATE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. AND ON THE EMISSIONS
YOU ARE CORRECT THAT WE'VE SEEN
A LOT OF REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IN TOTAL BUT IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
EMISSIONS AND WE HAVE NOT LINK
THOSE EMISSIONS TO THE CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS WHICH IS WHY. WE HAVE
SUCH STARK HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
VERY SELECT.
UNDERSERVED THEY'RE ALL
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS
OUTSIDE I DO SUPPORT US HELPING
YOU. CREATOR BUREAU OF.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE FOR.
US TO MAKE A STATEMENT OF HOW
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IS BUT THEN DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT AND IT'S A THREE AND HALF
MILLION DOLLAR ASK I THINK THAT.
IS. PRETTY SMALL COMPARED TO
SOME OF THE OTHER ASSETS THAT
ARE HERE BUT. EVEN STILL.
YEAH IT'S IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
WE CAN HELP SUPPORT YOU THINK
YOUNGSTERS WILL AND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN.
MISTER BRACERO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY IT'S NICE TO
SEE YOU I AM I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON THE
SUCCESSES THAT YOU HAVE HAD IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT.
.
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THOUGH.
I KNOW.
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED THAT YOU
ARE.
I THINK YOU'RE ASKING FOR TOO
MUCH SHOULD YOU STATE THIRTY
THREE. MILLION. MORE.
SO YOU WOULD NEED THIRTY THREE
MILLION MORE AND I UNDERSTAND
THIS IS THIS IS ALWAYS A CASE
WHERE YOU NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE. TO DO THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO I GET THAT WERE ALL
IN THAT SITUATION
BUT MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
PRECEDING YOUR TENURE IN THAT
OFFICE OF COURSE WAS GIVEN
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN SOME SUPPLEMENTAL MONEY TO
THE TUNE OF ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS.
TO GET THESE.
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE THEM THOSE
WHO ARE YOU NOW MENTALLY.
DISTURBED THOSE WHO SHOULDN'T
HAVE THEM ANYWAY AND WE'RE STILL
WE STOP ABOUT TEN THOUSAND GUNS.
OUT THERE WHICH
I THINK YOU KNOW NO MATTER WHAT
SIDE OF THE POLITICAL AISLE YOUR
ONLINE THAT BECAUSE YOU GRAY
CONCERNING OR CAUSES ME GREAT
CONCERN SO. I WOULD JUST LIKE
FOR YOU TO.
.
CAN YOU EIGHT CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MUCH LONGER IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO GET. THE REMAINDER OF
THOSE GUNS OFF THE STREET AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERY DAY YOU
HAVE SOME NEW PEOPLE ADDED TO
THE LIST I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT. THE
PEOPLE. WHO?
WHO YOU WERE GIVEN NOT YOU BUT
YOUR DEPARTMENT YOU'RE GIVEN
MONEY TO GO AFTER HOW MUCH
LONGER IS IT GOING TO TAKE
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT THE DATA?
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO TAKE
YOU MANY MORE YEARS TO BE ABLE
TO COLLECT ALL THOSE WEAPONS SO
COULD YOU JUST SPEAK THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION I'M GONNA TRY TO
KEEP THIS BRIEF AND.
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER HEARING TO
GET YOU ACTUALLY SO IF YOU COULD
JUST RESPOND ABOUT APPRECIATE
THAT RATE.
AND I'VE GOT A STEVE THEN THE
WHO IS THE. DIRECTOR OF THE
BUREAU FIREARMS WHO IS HERE WITH
ME AS WELL WHO CAN GIVE YOU MORE
DETAILS. ARE I KNOW THAT THE TWO
OF THE TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU MENTIONED AND
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A DIMENSION THAT
WE GOT WE GOT TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS A FEW YEARS
BACK.
TO START TO REALLY DEAL WITH THE
BACKLOG BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED
EVERY DAY MORE A WEEK THERE MORE
WEAPONS PRESS TO COLLECT BECAUSE
YOU'RE MORE PEOPLE WHO ON THIS
LIST WHO NO LONGER. HAVE THE
RIGHT TO POSSESS FIREARMS.
A IF.
WE HAD DONE NOTHING.
WE WOULD HAVE.
SOME.
STEVE KIRBY FROM RON BUT IT'S
FORTY SOME ODD THOUSAND OR SO.
HERE WE GO THINK WE GOT A NICE
HANDY CHART HERE.
THE BLUE LINE SHOWS YOU WHERE WE
WERE.
FOR WE WERE ABLE TO START
COLLECTING WEAPONS
AND AS YOU CAN SEE. WE WOULD BE
OVER FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
WEAPONS THAT WOULD BE OUT THERE
IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE GOOD WRITING THAT CHART
OKAY SO WE'RE DOWN TO TEN
THOUSAND. SO THIS IS WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH THAT THAT
RESOURCES THAT WE GOT BUT.
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
WEAPONS A COMMAND AND NOW THAT
THE THOSE WEAPONS THAT ARE STILL
OUT ARE PROBABLY HOPE BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE. MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
GET THEM FROM.
WHEN YOU HAVE TEAMS THAT HAVE
AND YOU DON'T GO OUT BY YOURSELF
TO GO COLLECT IT'S A TEAM.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
HAVE ENOUGH TEAMS TO GO OUT
THERE TO TRY TO COLLECT WEAPONS.
WOULD MAKE IT A REQUEST FOR
SOMEBODY TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
GO OUT THERE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A
VERY SUCCESSFUL OPERATION. NOT
ONE INCIDENT AND YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOLKS MANY OF THEM FELONS
WHO HAVE LOST THE RIGHT TO
POSSESS THESE WEAPONS BUT NOT
ONE INCIDENT WHERE ANYONE.
OBVIOUSLY NOT ARE SPECIAL AGENTS
OR OTHERS HAVE BEEN HARMED THIS
IS BEEN A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AND
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT. THE WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE US WE'VE WE
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THE ABILITY TO
BRING DOWN THE NUMBERS BUT TO
GET ITDOWN TO ESSENTIALLY
OPERATIONALLY ZERO WHERE YOU
STILL. HAVE A CONSTANT FLOW OF
IT WE WILL NEED SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES
SO HERE'S HERE'S MY QUESTION TO
YOU BECAUSE AGAIN THIS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS PROCEED YOU
BUT. IT'S YOUR BABY NOW SEVERAL
IT IS.
.
SO I HAVE THE CHART HERE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL MONEY FOR THE APPS
PROGRAM SO IF YOU COMBINE THAT
WITH.
THE TWENTY FOUR MILLION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED IT
COMES UP TO ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
SINCE.
BY TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TIME
PRINT
SO AND AT THAT TIME WE WERE
TOLD.
AND I THINK THE EXACT WORDS
WERE.
HOW MUCH WOULD YOU NEED IF YOU
COULD GIVE OUT ANY NUMBER WHAT
WOULD IT BE AND WE WERE TOLD
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS HOW MUCH WE NEED TO GET THE
JOB DONE?
AND IT'S NOW TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND THE JOB ISN'T DONE
SO. FOR ME IT'S. WHEN WE GONNA
LAND ON THE RIGHT NUMBER AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHEN WE'RE
GONNA GET THESE WEAPONS SO THAT
NO ONE GETS HURT.
BECAUSE IT WAS TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IT'S TURNED INTO SEVENTY
MILLION AND THAT'S STILL NOT
ENOUGH I KNOW BY THE WAY WE NEED
THIRTY THREE MILLION MORE FOR
THIS AND NINE MORE DID. YOU KNOW
TO POSITIONS FOR THAT I MEAN.
YOU YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS SIDE OF
THE DIET IS SO YOU GET WHERE I'M
COMING FROM MY HOPE.
AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHERE
WE ARE IN THIS PROCESS SYLMAR
LET ME AT ASK.
THE DIRECTOR MISTER LINDLEY TO
TRY TO RESPOND BECAUSE THAT IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WELL
AND THOSE MONIES I KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US. AND I KNOW THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE SO FAR BUT
LET ME SEE IF MISTER LINDE
CONTRACT CLARIFY ON THE NUMBERS.
SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION THAT
YOU AND OTHERS HAVE HAD WITH THE
GAPS PROGRAM BUT THERE ARE A
COUPLE THINGS THAT WE CAN'T
CONTROL. SO ONE IS THERE HAS
BEEN ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
SINCE OUR APPS
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. AND
THEN IN WHEN WE RECEIVED A GREAT
DEAL OF MONEY IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
FRANCIS LONGER RETENTION STARTED
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY FOURTEEN.
APPS PRIOR TO THAT WAS BASED
ONLY ON HAND IN INFORMATION.
HISTORICALLY HANDGUN AND LONG
GUN COM REGISTRATIONS ARE
PRODUCES ABOUT FIFTY FIFTY SO
NOW WE HAVE DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION.
THAT PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE THAT
CAN BE USED TO IDENTIFY PROHIBIT
PEOPLE ON TOP OF THAT WE'VE HAD
A LARGE INCREASE IN GUN SALES.
YOU KNOW STARTED TWENTY AROUND
TWENTY ELEVEN.
SO. WIN APPS WAS FIRST STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX CONSEILS
AROUND THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN GUN CELLS
ARE PEAKED AT ONE POINT THREE
I'M TRYING TO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
A GUN CELLS PETE AT ONE POINT
THREE MILLION. AND EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS REDUCED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OR SO IT HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND.
OUR GUNS HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE DEALING WITH
A MUCH LARGER NUMBER OF GUN
CELLS AND POTENTIALLY. FOUR MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BECOMING
PROHIBITED.
JUST KEEPING UP THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE WITH THE STAFFING THAT WE
HAVE.
DOES THE BEST WE CAN DO BUT FROM
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHT PEOPLE WERE
REMOVED FROM THAT LIST.
THAT'S NOT A VERY HIGH NUMBER.
WOW.
WE DID HAVE THAT YEAR IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH IT EIGHT THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
PEOPLE SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE REMOVED FROM THE LECTURE
TALKING FOR ONE YEAR TO THE
NEXT.
YOU ALSO HAVE YOU ARE AS WELL
YOU ALSO HAVE TO CONSIDER HOW
MANY PEOPLE WERE ADDED TO THAT
SYSTEM DURING THE SAME
TIMEFRAME.
SO WITH THE GRAPH THEREOF
SHOWING PEOPLE ARE ON THE LIST
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HOW MANY
GUNS YOU BEEN ABLE TO
CONFISCATED TO BAIT THE WHAT.
THE RELEVANCY IS HOW MANY PEOPLE
YOU'VE ACTUALLY GONE AND VISITED
TO TRY TO RETRIEVE THOSE WEAPONS
FOR. I'M NOT LIKE I GET IT IT'S
DANGEROUS WORK I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHY IS
THIS TAKING SO LONG AND WHY IS
IT WE NEED MORE MONEY WE NEED
MORE MONEY WHEN. WE ASKED
REACHED FOR THIS YOU KNOW THIS
GUY WHAT DO YOU WANT HOW MUCH
MONEY DO YOU NEED AND WE GAVE IT
TO THE DOJ AND.
WE'RE STILL NOT THERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK.
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH WE
TWENTY THIRTEEN ARE NOT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE OPERATING
UNDER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE NOW WE'VE
ADDED THE LONG GUNS TO THE LIST
VERSUS JUST THE.
THE REGULAR FARMS THAT WERE ON
THE LIST REGIONALLY OR WHETHER
IT'S A FACT THAT WE'VE SEEN THE
GUN PURCHASES GO UP DRAMATICALLY
IN THAT TIME.
AND BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SECURE WEAPONS FROM PEOPLE WHO
WERE MORE WILLING TO.
TURN THEM OVER PERHAPS IN THE
EARLIER YEARS AND SO NOW YOU
HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS WITH AND
TAKE A LOT MORE EFFORT.
BUT WHATEVER THE FACTOR IT'S IT
IT'S TAKING OUR VIA THE TIME
THAT YOU SEE. AND THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU SEE THE FUNDING THAT WE
GOT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN IS ABOUT
TO EXPIRE THIS IS ONLY TEMPORARY
FUNDING.
WITHOUT A REPRIEVE WE'RE GONNA
BE IN EVEN WORSE SHAPE WHEN IT
COMES TO TRYING TO REMOVE THOSE
WEAPONS. BUT I THINK WHAT YOU
CAN SEE IS THAT WE ARE
DEFINITELY REMOVING.
WEAPONS FROM THOSE WHO LOST THE
RIGHT TO POSSESS THEM
AND IT'S A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM I
WOULD SAY TO YOU THAT IF YOU
WANT US TO GIVE UP MORE THAN WE
HAVE MY TEAM COME A. BRIEF YOU
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS OR IF
THERE'S A NEAT YOU PROVIDE A
BREAKDOWN OF THE NUMBERS I'D
MORE THAN WE DO THAT I THINK
THERE'S ANYTHING TO HIDE IN THIS
PROGRAM. IT JUST THE TASK IT'S A
IT'S A. MONUMENTAL TASK BUT THE
ONLY STATE THAT DOES IT.
AND IT'S NOT AS IF WE CAN
LEARNED FROM OTHERS BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THIS.
IF THOSE WEAPONS HAD REMAIN
THOSE MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
WEAPONS EVERY REMOVED FROM
PEOPLE FAST YOU REMAIN IN THEIR
HANDS.
WE BE EVEN MORE PANICKED.
NO QUESTIONS.
ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
BOB ONE OF THANK YOU FOR COMING
WE'VE GOT THE LIST OF YOUR
REQUEST AND OUR STAFF WILL BE
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN RESULT WE
ACCOMPLISH.
IN THE BUDGET THIS COMING YEAR.
I THINK THE REQUEST A
REASONABLE IF WE EXPECT THINGS
TO HAPPEN AND WITH REPAIRS BILLS
THAT NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
SOMETIMES IT ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
THAT BUT WE DO OCCASIONALLY AND
SO I'VE GOT THE LIST.
Y. STEPHENS LIST AND WILL WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF VENTURE THANK
YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS. I JUST
HAD NO NOT ONLY QUICK QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE I THOUGHT IT WAS ABOUT
THE WEAPONS THAT WE WERE STILL
TALKING ABOUT.
I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU REAL
GENERALLY.
WHAT WOULD YOU ENVISION DOJ'S
ROLE? TO BE IN CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY WE HAD
ADDRESS SAID A BIT WITH THE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOINTS JONES
SAWYER.
.
WE'RE READY A IF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR WANT US TO JUMP
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO'VE DONE THIS
BEFORE DEALT WITH.
.
THINGS I CANNABIS.
SO WE'D BE READY WE JUST WOULD
NEED TO STAFF UP.
TELL THEM TO MEET THIS NEED
BECAUSE WE LOST AS A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER MENTIONED
WHEN HE WAS. DISCUSSING THIS
MATTER THAT WE LOST A GREAT
NUMBER OF PERSONNEL WHO ARE
EXPERT IN THIS.
BUT I DO AS I SAID BELIEVE WE
NEED A STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATION. WE HAVE A SHORT
WINDOW TO DO THIS RIGHT. WE NEED
TO BE THERE TO HELP LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
DO THE JOB BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES AYE AYE.
THINK ABOUT THE FOLKS IN THESE
RURAL COUNTIES THAT ARE MASSIVE
WE HAVE LOST SMALL. OUR AGENCIES
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IT IS A
BEAR AND SO WE HAVE A SEARCH
SHORT WINDOW TO GET THIS DONE.
WE'RE READY STEP TO THE PLATE SO
LONG AS THE OTHER RESOURCE ARE
PUT THERE BEFORE HAS I WOULD
ARGUE THAT OUR WINDOW IS ALREADY
OVER. A SENTRY GUARDING MADE
THIS SUBSTANCE. AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND OUR FORSMAN.
ASPECT IS
QUITE EMBARRASSING QUITE
HONESTLY. AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
MAYBE WE COULD EVEN CONSIDER
NARAL USING DOJ BUT MAYBE EVEN
MARRYING. THE BENEFIT OF THE
OTHER STATE AGENCY OF CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL TO WORK IN
CONCERT TOGETHER.
AND MAYBE HAVE
SOME PLAN THAT WE COULD
IMPLEMENT RIGHT AWAY.
BECAUSE WE NEED THE ENFORCEMENT
NOW WE NEEDED IT MONTHS AGO.
AND IT'S NOT A PLACE SO. WE'RE
READY THAT THAT'S MY REQUEST IS
THAT WE WOULD.
YOU WANT TO JOIN THE TWO
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND THANK YOU FOR COMING BENCHES
AND THANK YOU ALL THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
WHEN I MOVED TO ITEM NUMBER TWO.
WHICH IS ARE ANTITRUST WORKED
LOW.
OKAY.
OKAY LIBYA MANAGER CHRIS RYAN.
I CHIEF OF OPERATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
SO THIS THAT BE CP REQUESTS.
TWENTY THREE POSITIONS AND AND
A WHOLE.
AND.
IN THE FIRST YEAR BECAUSE ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
EIGHTEEN NOW.
IT WILL COME FROM FINANCE.
IMAGE I WORTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE.
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST FOR
ONGOING RESOURCES AS THEIR
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE
INCREASE THE WORKLOAD FOR THE
SECTION. I ALSO ANOTHER THESE
ARE SPECIAL FUNDS.
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE USED TO
FUND THE POSITIONS OF TO THE
EXTENT AND IT COMES FROM
SETTLEMENT SO TO THE EXTENT.
SETTLEMENTS DON'T COME IN WE CAN
ALWAYS RE EVALUATE THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES.
NO FINANCE OLEO.
ANY REALLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ARE
RECOMMENDING NOT APPROVING THE
MULTI YEAR PLAN.
IT WOULD EFFECTIVELY DOUBLE THE
STAFFING SIZE OF THE SECTION
INSTEAD WE ARE RECOMMENDING
APPROVING THE POSITIONS AND
RESOURCES REQUESTED FOR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT DOJ TO SUBMIT
A REPORT BY DECEMBER FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. ON ON THE
IMPACT OF THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDED IN THESE CAN INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE.
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT ARE
PURSUED AND INVESTIGATED AS WELL
AS THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT
GENERATE.
MONETARY RECOVERIES WE ARE
RECOMMENDING PROVIDING SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS THE
SECTION HAS REPORTED TURNING
AWAY OUR BACKLOG IN CASES AS
WELL AS ITS ATTORNEYS WORKING
SIGNIFICANT OVER TIME.
HOWEVER.
IT IS UNCLEAR AT THIS TIME
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS TOTAL
SUFFICIENT ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
TO JUSTIFY ALL OF THE REQUESTED
POSITIONS.
ON YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE WILL
SUFFICIENT NEW CASES BE
GENERATED AND THEN GENERATE THE
SETTLEMENT REVENUES BECAUSE
UNLIKE THE EXISTING POSITIONS
ALL OF THESE POSITIONS WILL BE
SUPPORTED BY THAT TYPE OF
REVENUE.
IT'S ALSO SYMBOLIC IS THAT IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE REQUESTED
POSITIONS WOULD BE ABLE TO
GENERATE SUFFICIENT REVENUE
CURRENTLY DOJ REPORTS THAT
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
ITS INVESTIGATED CASES TURN INTO
LITIGATION WITH THE POSSIBILITY.
OF GENERATING SETTLEMENT
REMINISCENCE UNCLEAR WHETHER
THIS PERCENTAGE WILL INCREASE
AND TO WHAT EXTENT TO GENERATE
THE REVENUES TO SUPPORT THE NEW
POSITIONS.
BUT.
YOU COME TO ANY OF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT ON THEY'LL USE A
YES MY NAME IS KATHLEEN FOOTE
I'M THE CHIEF OF THE ANTITRUST
UNIT WITHIN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AYE WITH REGARD TO SELL FUNDING
WHICH IS CERTAINLY LEGITIMATELY
A CONCERN OF YOURS.
THERE IS NO LACK OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF FUNDING
OF MANY OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
MATTERS THAT WEEK THAT WE
PURSUE.
ARE ACTUALLY NOT. MONEY
GENERATORS FOR THE SECTION A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE
FULLER A CASE THAT DATA. IDEA
TOURNEY GENERAL MENTIONED IN HIS
SIGHT AND HIS INITIAL REMARKS.
MERGERS IN GENERAL.
CAN BE INORDINATELY IMPORTANT
TO OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
CAN'T NECESSARILY RELY. ON
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO
PROTECT US.
WE HAVE SPECIAL ISSUES AND
SPECIAL NEEDS.
IN AREAS LIKE AGRICULTURE A IN
GENERAL WHAT HAPPENS IS IF IF
ITS A GOOD CASE THE PARTIES WILL
SIMPLY WALK AWAY FROM THE MERGER
THEY'LL ABANDON THE TRANSACTION.
BEFORE LAWSUIT IS FILED BY SO
THERE'S NO TRIAL AND THERE'S NO
WAY TO RECOUP. BY THE
INVESTIGATIVE COSTS.
SO.
TO TO MOVE ALL OF OUR RESOURCES
INTO PURSUING.
SO FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES HAS
NEVER MADE SENSE FOR THE SECTION
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY IT'S
NEVER BEEN FULLY SELF FUNDED
BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT IT ISN'T
SOME OTHER AREAS.
THERE'S NO LACK OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT BUT OF
COURSE IF WE PURSUE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES IT TAKES RESOURCES
AWAY FROM.
DOES OF THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE THINK UP MATTER.
IT AT LEAST AS MUCH IF NOT MORE
OUGHT TO TO THE ECONOMY BY IT IT
IT CERTAINLY.
IT WAIT WE CAN SHIFT THAT MIX.
IT ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE WOULD
RECOMMEND BUT WHAT IT WHAT IT
WOULD MEAN IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT. AT
WHATEVER LEVEL.
WE CAN MEET THE SELF FINANCING
NOT.
BECOME IT'S A QUESTION FROM
MEMBERS THIS LACKEY AGAIN JUST
REAL QUICK.
DISCUSSION PIECE OF IF I COULD
JUST USE SOME NUMBERS MAYBE.
I'M NOT SAYING IT STRAIGHT BUT
THIS IS THE NUMBERS AND LOOKING
AT.
THE AYE SEEMS TO BE ABOUT FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM A SPECIAL FUND INCREASE.
THE NUMBER OF.
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
POSITIONS.
FROM FOURTEEN TO TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS A.
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT INCREASE.
BUT WHEN INCREASE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF MATTERS AND I TRUST
SECTION CAN HANDLE BY ONLY EIGHT
PERCENT.
FOR A HUNDRED EIGHTEEN.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF HOURS.
OF WORK.
WOULD ONLY BE A HUNDRED THIRTY
WONDER POINT THREE PERCENT.
FOLKS FORTY THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY HOURS TO FORTY THOUSAND
THREE SEVENTY ONE.
SO DOING THAT MATTHEW WOULD COST
ABOUT THIRTY THREE THOUSAND.
SOME OF OUR THIRTY THREE DOLLARS
FOR EVERY EXTRA HOUR OF WORK.
IT'S PRETTY BIG NUMBER.
.
OUTSIDE KELSO WOULD BE.
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED TO FIVE
HUNDRED OR OF TOGETHER SIX
HUNDRED AND OUR.
SO IN SHORT IT SEEMS LIKE. THE
RETURN VERSE THE INVESTMENT.
AS A PROBLEM.
.
I'M NOT QUITE CERTAIN OF MATH
BUT I IF I COULD GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE.
OF.
BUT AT THE MOMENT EVERYONE IS
VERY VERY MY MATH IS OFF THAT NO
I'M NOT SAYING THAT YOU'RE
MATHIS OFF BUT I'M SAYING THAT.
WHAT WHAT THAT REFLECTS IS THAT
WE ARE? OF WHERE.
.
MY FOLKS ARE TOO THINLY
STRETCHED OVER TOO MANY MATTERS
RIGHT AT THE MOMENT. BY AND WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE FULLER A CASE WE
HAD SOMEONE DEVOTING HALF TIME.
TO THE INVESTIGATION.
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION AND KIND OF RELYING
ON THEM TO DO THE HEAVY LIFTING
IF.
THE NEED OCCURRED.
THEY WALKED AWAY SO ALL OF US
AND SUDDENLY WE HAD TO GO TO
COURT.
VERY DRAMATICALLY AND WE HAD TO
GO FROM A HALF A PERSON TO ABOUT
TEN PEOPLE. TO PREPARE THE CASE
WE FOUND SEVERAL OF THEM
INTERNALLY WE PULL THEM AWAY%
FROM OTHER. OTHER MATTERS LA BUT
WE WENT OUTSIDE.
FOR OUTSIDE COUNSEL AND THAT
AND THAT RAN US TO ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IT
WAS A BURN RATE OF ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND A WEEK. WHILE IT WAS
GOING ON.
.
IF YOU CAN'T ALWAYS PREDICT.
HOW THOSE THINGS WILL COME UP
BUT I WILL SAY THAT HAD WE BEEN
ABLE TO STAFF PROPERLY WHICH IS
LET'S SAY TWO? ATTORNEYS OF FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
.
WE STILL WOULD HAVE NEEDED MORE
WHEN THE MOMENT CAME BUT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE NEEDED AS MUCH
MORE WE WOULD HAVE BEEN.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO RELY IS
HEAVILY ON THE FEDERAL
ENFORCERS.
FOR.
FOR THE RESPONSE WHEN IT CAME.
BY AND WE WE JUST GENERALLY
WOULD HAVE HAD MORE A MORE
VIABLE.
ESSENTIALLY.
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY FOR. A FOR
MEETING THOSE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES AND IT'S MORE AND
MORE CLEAR. AYE IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
NEED TO MEET THOSE CHALLENGES.
SO IT'S GONNA BE A HEAVIER
EMPHASIS ON THE CASES THAT WILL
IN A NUMBER OF CASES GIVE US.
MORE ATTORNEYS FEES.
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY WILL APPLY
FOR ATTORNEYS FEES WHERE WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS WAS
THAT THERE APPEARS TO BE.
AN INCREASE IN WORKLOAD THAT IS
NOT SOME KIND OF THE MATCHING
COMPARABLE TO THE REQUEST FOR.
THE POSITIONS RIGHT IT DOUBLING
YOUR STAFFING.
GET YOU'RE NOT DOUBLING THE
WORKLOAD AND SO I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY A CONCERN THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED. THAT ELLIOT WAS
BROUGHT OUT IN A BIG MY MEMBER
HERE WAS BRINGING OUT THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO.
THING NAM ASSUMPTION IS THAT IF
YOU IF YOU W. STAFF MOSTLY
DOUBLING THE WORKLOAD UNLESS
YOU'VE WORKED EXTREMELY
UNDERSTAFFED AT THE BEGINNING.
SO ALL THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WE'D PROBABLY A LOT MORE
CLARIFICATION ON AND IT YELLOWS
RECOMMENDING THAT YOU GET NINE
POSITIONS ISSUE AND INTO AN
ASSESSMENT TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH
IS A YEAR AFTER SEE IF THAT'S
OKAY RATHER AN UPFRONT LOW
TWENTY THREE OF HIS
COMPOSITIONS.
FOUGHT IN THE BUDGET THAT
ATTACHED TO IT AND YET WOULD NOT
SHOOT THAT REALLY WHAT IS WANTED
BASED ON THE WORK CLOTHES THAT
YOU YOU'VE IDENTIFIED WORKLOAD
IT'S GOING TO INCREASE. BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM AS IF IT'S ON A
DOUBLE BUT I'M NOT SURE AS YOU
POINT OUT WHERE THE NOT THE
CURRENT WORKLOADS ADEQUATE. OF
BECAUSE THE ASSUMPTION
OFTENTIMES IF THAT IF YOU'RE
GETTING ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
THAT'S COMING IN THEN WILL FUND
THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. BUT IF
IT HAS NOT BEEN COMPARABLE FROM
THE BEGINNING VENUE NOT ONLY
FUNDING THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
BUT YOU'RE FUNDING THE BACKLOG
OF WORK THAT WAS NOT DONE. AND I
ASSUME THAT'S WHAT THE LOGIC IS
THAT THIS IT IT IS GIVING IN
MIND THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE A
PLAINTIFF SHOP FOR. SO IT'S NOT
THAT WE'RE GONNA WORK WORK WE
YOU WOULD RULE THE WHOLE THAT
OPEN
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
CONCERNING. THE WORKLOAD AND ITS
RELATIONSHIP TO THE REQUEST.
THIRD ITEM IS THE GAP BUREAU OF
GAMBLING IN CONTROL.
CHRIS RYAN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IN THIS PROPOSAL IS ONE POINT
SIX MILLION FOR SPECIAL FUND.
REQUESTING AN ARMY TATIAN FORGET
FROM THE GAMBLING CONTROL FUND
TO FUND TWELVE EXISTING
POSITIONS.
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY GRANTED
I'M AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM STAFF. DELEO.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING EXTENDING
THE FUNDING FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
YEAR RATHER THAN ON AN ONGOING
BASIS IS PROPOSED.
BEFORE YOU THIS WILL ALLOW DOJ
TO CONTINUE TO WORK DOWN THE
BACKLOG BUT WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE COLLECTION OF ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD DATA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EAT.
THE REASON WHY THIS ADDITIONAL
DATA IS NEEDED.
IS BECAUSE THE FULL IMPACT OF
ALL THIRTY TO LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED TO THE BUREAU TO WORK
DOWN THE BACKLOG. IS UNCERTAIN
AND WHEN I SEE THIRTY TWO IT'S
THE TWELVE THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS WELL AS TWENTY THAT
EXPIRE AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AND SO THE WORKLOAD IS
UNCERTAIN BECAUSE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS THE FIRST
YEAR IN WHICH NEARLY ALL OF THE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WILL BE
STAFFED I MEAN THAT'S POINT ONE.
LEADING THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT
ANALYSTS AS THEY HAVE BEEN
AROUND A BECOME MORE EXPERIENCED
THEY SHOULD BECOME MORE
PRODUCTIVE AND EFFICIENT
OVERTIME.
AND SO.
HAVE NOT HAVING THIS
INFORMATION ROOM MAKES IT REALLY
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF ONGOING
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR THE BUREAU
TO AVOID A PERMANENT LARGE
BACKLOG IN THE FUTURE. ANSWER
DOJ IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATING THAT
EACH OF ITS ANALYSTS ON AVERAGE
WILL CLOSE OUT APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN CASES. IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN HOWEVER
HISTORICALLY IT'S ANALYSTS HAVE
ACTUALLY CLOSE OUT A MUCH HIGHER
RATE OF CASES AND SO THIS
SUGGESTS THAT THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF CASES CLOSED IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SHOULD BE HIGHER
POTENTIALLY BY SEVERAL HUNDRED.
AND SO PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
FOR ONE ADDITIONAL YEAR AS WE
RECOMMEND MEANS THAT ALL OF THE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WILL
EXPIRE AT THE SAME TIME AT THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
DATA YOU WOULD HAVE THAT AS PART
OF YOUR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET DELIBERATIONS TO
THEN DETERMINE WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF ONGOING
RESOURCES NEEDED IN THE FUTURE.
WE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
IN A EL. FROM YES WITH. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION IS.
I APOLOGIZE I WAS IN ANOTHER
HONORING CITING GET THE
BEGINNING OF THE PRESENTATION
BUT.
THE POSITION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE.
KIND OF TEMPORARY RATE MOVING
OUT BUT THERE FULL TIME.
YES
THERE ARE REQUESTED
ARE THEY WERE LIMITED TERM.
SINCE THEY WERE NOW
ASKING BE MADE PERMANENT.
SO WE HAVE THIS PROBLEM IN THE
PAST WITH SOME OTHER DEPARTMENTS
I THINK THEY WERE ACTUALLY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHERE. IS
A SIMILAR SITUATION AND IT'S
HARD TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING
POSED BY OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES BECAUSE THAT IS A LEVEL
OF CERTAINTY THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
AND. THIS SITUATION IS KINDA
MORE UP IN THE AIR AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A. FAMILY ARE A FUTURE
YOU'RE TRYING TO PLAY ME LIKE
SOME CERTAIN TO GO ALONG WITH
THAT AND I'M ASSUMING THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AT HERE IS
THAT IN ORDER TO. KEEP AYE THE
PEOPLE YOU HAVE INVESTED THE
THOSE WHO HAVE THE SKILLS SUCH
ARE LOOKING FOR IN THE
EXPERIENCE.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THEM
IN THE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO.
CHYNA SOLIDIFY THEIR TO A
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND SO THAT
AND THAT WAS GONNA BE OUR.
R. COMMENT RELATED TO THE LA A
RECOMMENDATION IS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO RECRUIT ON
AN ON GOING OR TO HIRE PEOPLE AS
YOU JUST DESCRIBED WHEN IT'S
ONLY A ONE YEAR COMMITMENT.
SO JUST MAKES A VERY
CHALLENGING FOR US TO HIRE THOSE
POSITIONS RIGHT NOW I GET IT
OKAY THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THINKING MANAGER. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW IN THE AUDIENCE IN THE
THOSE IN FAVOR THE
RECOMMENDATION.
ANYONE WHO POSTS.
FAITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
ITEM TO WILL BE HELD OVER.
.
IF YOU NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS A
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND PROBATION
STATISTICAL SYSTEM.
SO AS WE UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE
YOU WERE LOOKING FOR A BRIEF.
JUST OVERVIEW OF THE SYSTEM AND
THEN I'LL PUT IT UP FOR SOME
QUESTIONS RIGHT YEAH PLEASE.
I AM ANNOUNCEMENT ON THE PROGRAM
MANAGER AND FOR THE STATISTICS
ON AT DOJ.
PROPEL GOOD SECTION ONE THREE
ZERO ONE. ZERO POINT BY THE DOJ
IS MANDATED TO COLLECT DATA
PERTAINING TO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR CRIMINAL
HISTORY AND STATISTICAL
PURPOSES.
THE JUVENILE COURT INFORMATION
STATISTICAL SYSTEM AS THE
PRIMARY SYSTEM STATEWIDE
DATABASE OF INFORMATION
COLLECTED FROM COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ON ALL JUVENILE
PROBATION REFERRALS COURT
ACTIONS AND FINAL DISPOSITIONS.
THE SYSTEM COLLECTS AND COMPILES
DATA ON THE NUMBER OF JUVENILES
REFERRED TO THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT PURSUANT TO WELFARE
INSTITUTION CODE SECTION SIX
ZERO ONE. AND ARE SIX ZERO TWO.
THE SYSTEM ALSO MAINTAINS DATA
ON A DEFINED UNIVERSE OF DATA
ELEMENTS FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
JUVENILE WHOSE IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION IS ENTERED INTO THE
SYSTEM.
COUNTIES MUST SUBMIT DATA INTO
THE GC PSS ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
EITHER IN MANUAL DATA ENTRY OR
THROUGH THE WEB ENABLED
UPLOADING PROCESS
COUNTIES THE ENTER DATA MANUALLY
VIA THE WEB ENABLED APPLICATION.
MAY ENTER IT THROUGHOUT THE
MONTH AND COUNTIES THAT SUBMIT
DATA VIA THE UPLOAD PROCESS MUST
SUBMIT THE DATA BY THE TENTH
WORKING DAY OF THE FOLLOWING
REPORTING PERIOD.
THERE IS A WIDE FIRE WIDE
VARIATION IN THE WAY THE
COUNTIES. COMPLY WITH THE DAISY
PS AS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
MOST LIKELY DEPENDENT UPON THE
SOPHISTICATION OF THE LOCAL DATA
SYSTEMS.
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE DATA
WORKING GROUP HAS ESTABLISHED
WAS ESTABLISHED TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ON THE MUST BILL AND
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH REPORTED
ON FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AIMED AT. OPTIONS FOR IMPROVING
INTER AGENCY COORDINATION
MODERNIZATION AND UPGRADING OF
STATE AND LOCAL JUVENILE JUSTICE
DATA AND INFORMATION SYSTEMS TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AMONG THE FINDINGS THE
REPORT STATES THAT COMPREHENSIVE
OUTCOME DATA INCLUDING
RECIDIVISM IS NOT CURRENTLY
TRACKED AND MAY NOT BE TRACKABLE
THROUGH THE JP JC PSS SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THE DATA BILLS IS BILL
ON OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY. THE
REPORTED THE REPORT CITED
ADDITIONAL LIMITATIONS OF THE
DECSS INCLUDING THE
UNAVAILABILITY OF DATA RELATED
TO ADULT COURT DISPOSITIONS.
PLACEMENT OUTCOMES BY THE TYPE
OF FACILITY AND WELLNESS
OUTCOMES INCLUDING EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH AND CHILD WELFARE
STATUS.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY ANY
QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER STONE.
SO CLEARLY WOULD BE HAVE AN
OUTDATED SYSTEM AND PART OF THIS
REQUEST REALLY COMES THROUGH ME.
BECAUSE I'M VERY INTERESTED IN
THE IN DATA AND DATA COLLECTION.
AND BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
AND TRACK SPECIALLY JUVENILES
WHO THE PROCESS THEN AS THEY GO
INTO THE ADULT PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF RECIDIVISM
SO WE REALLY. KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WHAT THE LAY OF THE
LAND AS.
SO PART OF THE QUESTION IS HOW
INTERESTED ARE YOU IN UPDATING
THE SYSTEM WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
UPDATE THE SYSTEM HOW DO WE
START TO GET.
THE DATA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED ULTIMATELY TO TO REALLY DO
THE POLICY THAT WE NEED. WE'VE
BEEN.
MOVING FOR POLICY AND RECORD
CEILING WE'VE BEEN MOVING FOR
POLICY ON PROTECTING YOU THINK
GIVING THEM A SECOND CHANCE ON.
REALLY LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
CONNECTIONS TO THE SYSTEMS.
THE DATA IS KIND OF. THE DATE IS
LACKING SO HOW DO WE GET FROM
WHERE WE ARE NOW TO A SYSTEM
WHERE WE HAVE. ADEQUATE DATA TO
BE ABLE TO KNOW THE POLICY WE'RE
DOING IS WORKING AND START TO
EXPAND THAT POLICY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR KIDS.
I DEFINITELY THINK IT'S A WHERE
THE DISCUSSION TO HAVE BUT I
THINK WE'RE NOT THE ONLY PARTNER
INVOLVED IN IN THIS PROCESS. I
THINK NGUYEN JCPS WAS INITIALLY
ESTABLISHED IT WAS PURELY FOR
STATISTICAL PURPOSES AND IT
REALLY DOESN'T TRACK A JUVENILE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM IS TALKING A
REFERRAL THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT REFERRAL.
AND SO YOU MIGHT HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL IN THERE ARE MULTIPLE
TIMES IF THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
REFERRALS AND SO TO BE CHANGING
THE WHOLE BASIS AND FOUNDATION I
THINK THE UNIT OF MEASUREMENT.
OF THE SYSTEM SO THAT WOULD THAT
REQUIRES SOME.
FURTHER DISCUSSION I THINK WITH
WITH MANY OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED.
AND THAT IS A THRESHOLD QUESTION
IS HOW INTERESTED IS DOJ AND. IN
PURSUING THIS IF WE WERE TO
START TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
AND REALLY LOOK AT. THE THAT THE
DATA COLLECTION AND AND HOW WE
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ROBUST AND
ALL THAT UNFUNDED. RIGHT AND
THAT'S HOW IT INDICATE WAS I NOT
HER DID YOU EARLIER RIGHT YEAH.
YEAH NON UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE
THE TIME WELL WORTH IT FOR US.
TO INVEST IN IN IN IN A SOLID
DATA SYSTEM IF WE CAN GET THERE
NOW THE CAT GOT IS WE'VE HAD
LOTS OF OTHER DATA SYSTEMS THAT
WE'VE BEEN. EMBARKED ON THAT
HAVE BEEN COLOSSAL FAILURES AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THROWN DOWN THE DRAIN SO.
FIRST THING WE NEED TO KNOW IS
THE WILLINGNESS.
WILLINGNESS OF OF THE PARTNERS
TO TO GO GET THE STATE I THINK I
THINK THAT IT'S NEED I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT. THAT HOW WE PUT TOGETHER
MAKE SURE WE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE DATA SYSTEM THAT'S
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND
FUNDS. THEIR THEIR CREATION OF
OF THE SYSTEM BUT. WE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE WE HAVE.
STAY CLOSE RIGHT EVERYBODY
REALLY WILLING TO IT DESIGNED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORKS SO THAT WE
CAN TRACK.
PEOPLE THROUGH THAT TO THE
PROGRAM.
SO I AS I INDICATED EARLIER I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT IT
YEAH I WOULD JUST CAUTION YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH WE CAN COMMIT
VERSUS HOW MUCH WERE FUNDED TO
DO BUT IT'S THAT CONVERSATION
WOULD BE WILLING TO HAVE. A WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN AND IS ILL
ALISON INDICATED THERE ARE OTHER
PARTIES.
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT WOULD NEED TO
BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION AND
MUCH OF THE DATA RESIDES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL RIGHT RIGHT. AND SO
HAVING A STATEWIDE SYSTEM FOR
COLLECTING THAT CREATES OTHER
FISCAL ISSUES.
FOR THE LOCALS AS WELL.
SO I THINK IT'S IT'S STEP BY
CONVERSATION WE CAN HAPPEN AND
AS YOU INDICATE SAW EARLIER AT
THE AGE IS VERY INTERESTED IN
AND MANY THINGS BUT AGAIN. WE
CAUTION HOW MUCH. WE CAN COMMIT
GIVEN YOU KNOW THE FUNDING
RESOURCES WE HAVE AVAILABLE AND
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING.
NO I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I'M NOT
ASKING.
TO.
THEY EXPEND MONEY NOW TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM I WOULD TRY TO DEFINE
THE PROBLEM MAKE SURE LEADING WE
KNOW WHAT'S.
POTENTIALLY WHAT'S NEED BUT HOW
WE DESIGN IT AND HAVE A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM THAT'S KIND OF
TOP DOWN. DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK I
THINK WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES
WERE WHO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
FUNNY WHAT THEY DO HAVE AND CAN
DO AND THEN INSURE THAT THAT
THERE'S A WAY FOR THAT DATA THEN
TO GET COLLECTED UP SO THAT WE
CAN START TO. ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS.
BUT THERE IS A STATE INTEREST IN
THIS BECAUSE OF THE THERE ARE A
LOT OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND.
JUVENILES TEND TO MOVE COUNTY TO
COUNTY DIFFER PROGRAM SPECIAL IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM NOW
EVEN JUST INVOLVED JUSTICE.
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO A NUMBER OF
PROBATION OFFICES AND SWITCHING
SOME OF THE SMALLER COUNTIES
LOOKING IT REGIONAL RESOURCES TO
HELP.
HELP THEM SOLVE SOME ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE IS SOMETHING THAT A
NUMBER OF THEM ARE INTERESTED
AND. SO IN THIS BROADER
CONVERSATION HAVING BAD DATA TO
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING AND AND THAT'S WHAT NEXT
ERECTIONS ARE. IT'S IT'S GONNA
BE ULTIMATELY VERY IMPORTANT.
UNDERSTOOD.
CAN IT IN THE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW.
THIS.
O'DONNELL PUBLIC COMMENTS ARE
YOU IN FAVOR OPPOSED.
IN FAVOR DIRECTIONS.
OH OKAY ONE IN FAVOR.
I CAN HEAR YOU I'M ABOUT ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE HIGHEST IN START.
AND I SERVICES STATE LAST YEAR
JUVENILE JUSTICE DATA WORKING
GROUP THAT WAS CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE BACK IN AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN. WE ARE ISSUED.
ALIKE TO HEAR SEVENTY PAGES OF
REPORT. OF LOOKING
COMPREHENSIVELY AT A JC PSS THE
ITEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
AND ALL NEEDS A ACROSS THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR
PERFORMANCE OUTCOME MEASURES FOR
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES. AND JUST
FOR IMPROVEMENT OF THE DATA
SYSTEM ITSELF.
OUR NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION
WAS TO REPAIR THE BROKEN
JUVENILE COURT AND I AM
PREVENTION STATISTICAL SYSTEM.
AND I COULD TAKE UP MORE TIME
GOING THROUGH A LITANY OF WHAT'S
WRONG. ONE OF THE KEY FACTORS
THAT'S MISSING IS WE HAVE NO
CAPACITY.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THIS STATEWIDE DATABASE
TO COLLECT RECIDIVISM DATA ON
CHILDREN MOVING THROUGH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
THAT'S REALLY. THE GOLD STANDARD
IS THE BEST PRACTICE STANDARDS.
VETS BACKED.
BY A NATIONAL ONE AGENCIES THE
COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS.
THE PEW CHARITABLE TRUST.
WE NOTED ALSO IN OUR REPORT
THAT.
IN OTHER YOUTH SERVING ROAMS.
WE HAVE MADE A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN UPGRADING THE
SYSTEMS THAT SUPPORT THE POLICY
CHANGES WE MAKE. ON THE CW S.
CMS ARE CHILD WELFARE DATA
SYSTEM AT ALL UC BERKELEY.
THE CAL PADS.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE EDUCATION
DATA NETWORK NO INVESTMENT FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS HAS BEEN
MADE. IN UPGRADING THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE DATA SYSTEM THE STATE
MAINTAINS AT DOJ. NOTHING IN
MEANWHILE THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS MOVING.
INTO A TRANSFORMATIONAL MODE
WERE CHANGING THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE SYSTEM OR ADDING NEW
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVEN'T GOT THE
CAPACITY WE NEED.
TO ANALYZE THEM SO OUR HOPE IS
THAT WHAT WILL COME OUT OF THIS
PROCESS.
IS A DIRECTIVE OR A REQUIREMENT.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WOULD COME UP WITH SOME KIND OF
A PLAN. WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
PERHAPS A YEAR BY NEXT MARCH.
FOR WHAT IT WOULD TAKE ONE OF
THE OPTIONS FOR UPGRADING. JCPS
US SO WE CAN HAVE THE CAPACITY
WE NEED TO ANALYZE THE PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES
WE'RE GOING FORWARD WITH SO.
THERE'S A SPIRIT OF WORKING
TOGETHER HERE.
TO MEMBERS OF THE JUPITER.
WHEN. I'M DONE.
SO THAT'S IT SO WE'RE JUST
HOPING NOT FOR AN APPROPRIATION
BUT FOR.
FORWARD MOVEMENT ON A PLAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
A FAVOR ALL BE BRIEF MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHEAPER PATIENT OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
WERE CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO DOT
DATA DRIVEN DECISION MAKING AND
WOULD VERY MUCH WANT TO BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WITH AYE
THIS COMMITTEE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE WITH DOJ ARE OUR
PARTNERS ON MR STEINHARDT AND
OTHERS.
WITH THAT THE SYSTEM CERTAINLY
IS.
OUTDATED AND IN NEED OF SOME
REVISIONS BUT I THINK THE
IMPORTANT PIECE WILL BE. LOOKING
AT WHAT WE NEED OR WE GO TO THE
NEXT PHASE AS DEFINING THE MOST
MEANINGFUL DATA NOT JUST
NECESSARILY BUILDING UPON WHAT
CURRENTLY IS BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT THE STRUCTURE THAT. THE
VARIABLES THAT ARE ARE IN THE
SYSTEM LOOK DIFFERENT NOW AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
COLLECTING THE RIGHT KIND OF
DATA.
FROM BOTH THE POLICY
PERSPECTIVE AND FROM
IMPLEMENTATION AND OPERATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE PARTIES
TOWARDS ADEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR.
DISCUSSING ITEM WE'VE WE
RECEIVED A NUMBER OF LEVELS
LETTERS FROM DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AS WELL. AT ALL SAYING PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME THING THAT WE NEED
TO UPDATE OUR A DATA SYSTEM.
THAT WE ARE WE EXPENDED OFF A
LOT OF MONEY AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE IN THE STATE YET WE'RE
NOT SURE WHETHER THAT'S
AFFECTED.
BECAUSE OF WE DON'T HAVE THE
DATA IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM THE
MONEY THAT WAS SPINNING IS IS
WE'RE NOT SURE WE'RE DOING IT
AND EVERYTHING BECOMES.
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION ABOUT A
CHILD WHO DID WHATEVER BUT IT
MAY NOT BE THE NORM AND SO FOR
CLEARLY WE NEED TO DO THIS.
IT'S NICE THAT WE ARE BEING
OFFERED TO WORK WITH IT
INDIVIDUALS AND IT WAS A STONE
IS INTERESTED IN IT. AND BUT
WHAT IF SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO BEGIN TO DO THAT ONLY HERE
BUT WE ASKING FOR IT ALSO AND
OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL. OUGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING IN TERMS OF WHICH
CHANGING POLICIES AND DOING
THINGS AND WE ABILITY ASIAN THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY WORKING. AND THAT
WENT SOMETHING IS WORKING WE
NEED TO EXPAND ON IT AND WHAT IS
NOT WORKING WE NEED TO FIND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE KNOW THAT
WILL WORK. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT ITEM FOUR IS HELD OVER
THAT SEAT A JUVENILE JUSTICE.
.
DATA INFORMATION WILL NOT ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS
EXPANSION.
THANK YOU ALL.
TWO ITEMS HERE.
OKAY. GREAT. SO WE BEGIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS
EXPANSION.
MADAM CHAIR I'M DAVE BALLROOM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
THIS ITEM OF PROPOSED A SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWELVE R. P. Y.. TO.
IN AN EFFORT THAT GOES OVER
SEVERAL YEARS THAT WILL.
RAPIDLY EXPAND DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND THE SIZE OF CALIFORNIA
CADET CORS. COVERING CAN
ACCORDS BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN ELEVEN IT WAS.
FORMED AT THE TIME BY THE MY
PREDECESSOR GENERAL EDWIN FORBES
WE SAW THE WINDS OF WORLD WAR
ONE COMING AND KNEW THAT.
AMERICA WAS GOING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT ROLE ON THE GLOBAL
STAGE AND HE DIDN'T FEEL THAT
THE YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA REPORT
PREPARED.
TO BE THE BUSINESS LEADERS THE
ACADEMIC LEADERS ON THE LTIR
LEADERS. THAT TIME TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE IN THAT ENVIRONMENT SO
YOU FORMED A PROGRAM THAT PRIDE
MILITARY TRAINING MILITARY
DISCIPLINE TO AUGMENT ACT
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE WITH IN
HIGH SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A FIFTY FIVE
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM WITH SIX THOUSAND CADETS
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE.
HOW WILL WE BE ABLE TO SERVICE
ABOUT TWENTY TWO THOUSAND CADETS
STATEWIDE?
THE PROGRAM PRODUCES SOME PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE RESULTS.
IF A CHILD OR STUDENT IS
ENROLLED IN THE CALIFORNIA KEPT
CONNECT OR THEIR NINETY PERCENT
LIKELY TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL ON TIME. AS OPPOSED TO
STATEWIDE AVERAGE OF EIGHTY
PERCENT.
MORE POORLY THERE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO GET INTO COLLEGE.
SO WE'VE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
VERY VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAM. THE
MONEY THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
WOULD FIND STATEWIDE SERVICES
AND PEOPLE THAT FROM THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SOME TRAINING CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT AND STATEWIDE
SUPPORT TO THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ALREADY SPENDING LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING. TO HIRE THE.
CADRE OF THE MULTI FACULTY AT
EACH OF THE SCHOOLS APART
BATES.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
WHAT WE HEAR FROM OUR VILLAGE?
UNIFORM BUT.
JOSH DUGGAR DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
WHICH IS.
ECHO THE THE WORDS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MILITA PARCHMENT
THAT.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AND WORTH THE
INVESTMENT IN THAT THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES BEING
PROVIDED WILL HELP PROVIDE A
UNIFORM EXPERIENCE ACROSS ALL
SCHOOLS THE. EXISTING SCHOOLS.
AS WELL AS THOSE BEING EATEN UP
PART OF THE EXPANSION.
YEAH FELLOW.
A AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RUN LET US WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
BOB WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FEDERAL FUND.
APPROPRIATIONS TO EXPAND THE
CADET CORPS BECAUSE IT IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE GENERAL
APPROACH OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMER HEALTHY FF.
FOR SUPPORTING EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT INVESTMENTS
WE ALSO CONTINUE TO SEE ISSUES.
WITH THE BUDGET REQUEST DETAILS
JUSTIFYING FEE.
ACTUAL LEVEL OF A REQUESTED
FUNDING.
ARE WE FIND THAT THE CURRENT
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
MODEL.
DOES ENABLED SCHOOLS WITH THE
AUTONOMY AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
FIND. THE CAT CORPS PROGRAMS
THEMSELVES THE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH. ALL THEIR VALUE TO THOSE
SCHOOLS ARE RELATIVE TO OTHER.
AVAILABLE EDUCATIONAL THAT
SMITH'S
ARE THE CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS
DALLAS AND TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN I MOVED THE STATE
FUNDING FOR PRIMARY EDUCATION
AWAY FROM CATEGORICAL FUNDING.
ULTRABASE PER PUPIL FUNDING
MODEL.
WITH ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION FUNDING FOR
ENGLISH LEARNER AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AYE TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THESE.
.
OR THAT THERE ARE STILL SOME
CATEGORICAL FUNDING OF EDUCATION
PROGRAMS BY THE STATE. OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE RELATIVELY FEW IN
NUMBER. AND.
HAVE A MUCH SMALLER FUNDING
AMOUNTS.
AND RECEIVE THEIR ALLOCATIONS
FROM THE PROBLEM ANY EIGHT.
CARVE OUT.
OF LOGIC JOURNAL FUND RATHER
DIRECTLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
A PRIMARY RATIONALE FOR THIS
MODEL A WAS TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THE FLEXIBILITY.
TO SPEND RESOURCES ON LOCAL
PRIORITIES AT LEVEL THAT THEY
SEE FIT.
RATHER AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
STATE.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY HOW THE
CURRENT FIFTY ONE PARTICIPATING
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY FUND THEIR
PROGRAMS.
I WE KNOW THAT IF A SCHOOLS FIND
THIS PROGRAM JULIE BECAUSE THEY
STUDENTS TO HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED ADVOCATES WILL OUTCOMES
THEY SHOULD BE WILLING TO
PRIORITIZE THAT THEIR CURRENT
FUNDING FOR IT JUST AS THEY
WOULD ANY OTHER.
POTENTIAL ENRICHMENT PROGRAM
THAT THEY HAVE.
JUST LET ME KNOW THAT THE LOCAL
I. CONTROL FUNDING. FORMULA.
I'VE FUNDING HAS INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY FOR SCHOOLS IN
RECENT YEARS.
LA FINALLY WE ALSO NOTE THAT
THE BUDGET REQUEST DETAILS
SUBMITTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD TO HAVE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
IN SOME CASES.
THEY'RE STILL IN SUFFICIENT
DETAIL.
THAT WE WERE PROVIDED SUCH AS
THE LOCAL JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL STATE LEVEL
STAFF.
I KNOW CASES IT WOULD TAKE ISSUE
WITH.
THE ACTUAL LEVEL OF RESOURCES
REQUESTED AYE AS IS THE CASE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
REQUEST FOR EXAMPLE FOR.
THE
FUND BY PERCENT THE COST OF THE
FULL. UNIFORM SET FOR EVERY YEAR
FOR EVERY CADET CORPS
COMMANDANT.
WHETHER TO NOT THEY ARE NEWLY
RECRUITED OR. I RETAIN FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS.
MORE OVER THE MUCH OF THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE BASED ON
VERY AGGRESSIVE MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM.
THE EXPANSION PROJECTIONS WHICH
MAY NOT BE REALIZED YOU
THEREFORE DO NOT BELIEVE.
THAT A MULTI YEAR REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES EVEN FROM
BUDGET ITEMS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY SUPPORTED BY THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT IS A AT THIS
TIME WARRANTED UNTIL.
THE CADET CORPS CAN.
DEMONSTRATE ITS ACTUAL RATE OF
EXPANSION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
ISSUES MELINDA. THINK MADAM
CHAIR.
IS SO.
YOU SAID THAT HE CALIFORNIA
CADET CORPS KINDA CAME ON THE
HEELS OF THE WAR RIGHT.
.
HOW MANY OF YOU ARE CAN DEBTS GO
ON? TO MILITARY SERVICE ONCE I
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
SH SO WE DON'T WE DON'T TRACK
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM JUNIOR
OUR TO SEE WHICH IS A FEDERAL
PROGRAM IS. DESIGNED TO
INCULCATE MILITARY IDEAS INTO
KIDS STICK WITH THE GOAL OF GET
YOUR HAVING THEM JOIN ONE OF THE
SERVICES. ARSES PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
SO THEY CAN BECOME. BETTER
CITIZENS AND BETTER LEADERS
LEADERS IN WHATEVER. PATH THEY
CHOOSE TO FALL.
SO IS IT LIKE GOD I AM YOU
FORGIVE ME I'M JUST I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROGRAM I
HAVE FIVE KIDS IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
I NEVER HEARD OF THIS PROGRAM SO
IT'S.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE ONE OF THE FIFTY
FIVE THAT YOU'RE IN.
IS THIS LIKE JROTC ARE THEY
WEARING UNIFORMS EVERYDAY TO
CHARITIES WHO WAS MODELED AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA CONNECT OR.
OF THOSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S OF VALUE WHAT WE
WERE DOING IN CALIFORNIA AT SOME
POINT. IN THE FIFTIES OR SIXTIES
AND ADOPTED THAT THAT SAME
CREDIT PROGRAM BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING GEARED TOWARD.
MILITARY SERVICE IT IS A
MILITARY ENVIRONMENT SO THE KIDS
WILL COME IN AND DEPENDING ON
THE SCHOOL WEAR THE UNIFORM
EITHER ONE DAY WAKE WHEN SOME
SCHOOLS THEY WEAR UNIFORMS. ALL
THE TIME.
AND.
AND SELECTIVE CLASS
SO INSTEAD OF TAKING BAND OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT YOU TO
CALIFORNIA TECH WAR WHERE THE
TEACH LEADERSHIP TO TEACH PLAN
NAVIGATION.
SOME MILITARY SCIENCE THEY DO
ENCAMPMENTS THEY DO DRILL
COMPETITIONS.
IS THIS FOR.
.
IS THIS FOR KIDS WHO ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY IN SCHOOL OR IS THIS
FOR KIDS WHO ARE. THE HYATT
CHEEVER'S ANYONE IN IN ANY OF
THE SCHOOLS THAT THERE'S A ROLE
ANY ANY KID CAN PARTICIPATE.
OKAY THANK YOU. ANY OF
QUESTIONS.
ANY PRO FROM THE AUDIENCE
YES.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS SET TO READ. A
BRIEF STATEMENT THAT'S NOW THAT
YOU'RE IN FAVOR OF IT OR NOT YES
YES MY NAME IS SET THREE WITH
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
HA BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA'S AMVETS DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS VETERANS
COUNCIL MILITARY OFFICES
SOCIALIZATION. OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL GUARD SOCIALIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
ANY ANYONE IN ANY OPPOSITION
ANYONE OPPOSED.
OKAY ANY OF THE BOOK THANK YOU
FOR THE UP PRESENTATION WILL
LOOK OVER I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS.
AND AND HAS SOME VALIDITY IS
THAT.
WE HAVE.
I GUESS THE OTHER IN THE FIFTY
ONE SCHOOLS OF IT YOU HAVE A
BECAUSE FIFTY ONE FIFTY FIVE.
SCHOOLS YOU HAVE ARE BASICALLY
FUNDED THROUGH LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA IS THAT CORRECT
THAT BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE ABOUT
WE HAVE ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDES THE.
STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT AND WET WITH
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
WOULD. I'M UNABLE US TO DO IS TO
EXPAND THAT TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
TRAINING AND CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT TO.
OVER THREE TIMES MORE SCHOOLS
WHICH CONTINUES SIR COULD
SERVICE NOW THE PROBLEM WITH LCC
OFFICE IS NOT APPROPRIATE TO USE
LCD FF NOR IS THERE EVEN A
MECHANISM. TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THAT BACKWARDS TO DEVELOP
STATEWIDE PROGRAMS.
SO THIS ENABLES THE STATE TO
HAVE CONTINUITY THROUGHOUT THE
PROGRAMS WE CAN HAVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROGRAMS AND WE CAN HAVE
EFFICIENCIES AND. UNIFORM
PURCHASES BECAUSE WE CAN BUY
UNIFORMS AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
MASS OTHER LESS EXPENSIVE THAN
IF THE SCHOOL HAD TO RUN OUT.
AND RUN ITS OWN SO IN ORDER TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE.
UNIFIED PROGRAM STATEWIDE WAS
STATEWIDE STANDARDS IT REQUIRES
A STATEWIDE INVESTMENT.
SO.
IN ADDITION TO.
JUST BASICALLY MAKING SURE THAT
YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT YOU ALSO WAS TALKING
ABOUT BUYING UNIFORMS AND
EVERYTHING ALSO DRIVES A
PROGRAM.
THE UNIVERSE CURRENTLY A PAID
FOR BY WHOM THE SCHOOL SITES ARE
CURRENTLY PAID FOR BY THE STATE
ABOUT THE STATE OKAY THAT'S OUT
OF THE ONE POINT. FIVE MILLION
ONE POINT.
ONE BY THINGS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION AT. ANY RATE THE IT IS
INADEQUATE WE.
WE CAN'T KEEP UP EVEN WITH THE
DEMAND FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE.
OKAY PRIMARY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY OF
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER IF
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO THINK WE NEEDED TO SEEK. OUT
ONE OF THE LEGACIES OF THE THEM
CHALLENGES THAT WERE ASKING ME
ASKED TO UP.
.
YOU KNOW TO DO MORE AND AND AND
OBVIOUSLY SET UP THESE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING IS THAT THIS
THAT OF THE SCHOOLS HAVE AGREED
THEY WOULDN'T DO.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD RELY ON LC
AFFAIR SAYS REALLY COMPLICATED
SAME THING WITH FELLOW KRETEK
EDUCATION. AND ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WITH THEIR THAT
SHOULD BE COVERED IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULAS.
SO WILL LOOK AT THIS AND SAY
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS TO ESTABLISH A
MILITARY DEPARTMENT I THINK THIS
WAS AS WELL. PRESENCE AT THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY INSTITUTE
AND PORTABLE MILITARY. WITH
THIS.
PER REQUEST
WOULD DO IS ENABLE US TO EXPAND
THE MODEL THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED
THAT THE LOCAL MILITARY
INSTITUTE OVER SEVENTEEN YEARS
AGO. FOR A.
.
FOR A SCHOOL THE CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT FOCUSES ON HIGH PERFORMING
KIDS.
AND DISADVANTAGED AREAS ARE
DISTRICTS
FOR KIDS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
NOT BE AVAILABLE OR OR HELP HAVE
THE RESOURCES.
AT HOME OR IN SCHOOL TO BECOME
COMPETITIVE TO GET INTO COLLEGE
AND WE DO THAT AT THE LOCAL
MILITARY INSTITUTE.
THIS WOULD EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO
A. PORTABLE THAT STARTED
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL IN PORTERVILLE
AND THEN ONE IN RIVERSIDE.
OKAY THE ARM THE REQUEST IS FOR
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
AND TWENTY ONE P. WHY IN THE. IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND THEN THAT
WILL ON.
THE A STEADY STATE OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
ENABLES US TO PUT CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT CADRE.
MOSTLY CALIFORNIA ACTUAL GUARD
SOLDIERS OR AIRMEN THAT TEACH
THE.
LEADERSHIP CLASSES IN THESE. IN
THE SCHOOLS AND ALSO ASSIST WITH
I'M RUNNING THE SCHOOL IN THE
GOOD ORDER AND DISCIPLINE IN THE
SCHOOL. THE RESULTS OF THE LOCAL
MILITARY AN INSTITUTE OR EVEN
MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN THOSE OF
THE CADET CORPS. IF A STUDENT
ENROLLS IN THE OPEN MILITARY
INSTITUTE THERE NINETY SIX
PERCENT. FROM LIKELY TO GRADUATE
ON TIME AND EVERYONE THE
GRADUATES COMPLETES OUR AGE
THROUGH G..
REQUIREMENTS.
LAST YEAR'S GRADUATING CLASS OF
ABOUT EIGHTY KIDS ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE KIDS GRADUATED
THAT WENT THROUGH. OF THOSE ALL%
BUT FIVE WHEN ON TO EITHER TO
YOUR FOR YOUR CIVILIAN SCHOOLS
OF THE REMAINING FIVE THREE WENT
TO ONE OF OUR SERVICE ACADEMIES.
AND TO ENLIST IN THE MILITARY SO
IT IS IT IS VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN THIS REQUEST IS FOR US TO
ESTABLISH CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WHICH IS KIND OF UNUSUAL.
SO THE THAT WE WILL PARTNER
WITH.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN EACH OF
THOSE DISTRICTS
AND THEN.
THE THE MILITARY PART WHEN THE
STATE PROVIDES THE.
MELTER SUPPORT TO THOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS SO THERE WILL BE A
SCHOOL BOARD AND A SEVEN EIGHT
THEN THERE'LL BE SPONSORED
CHARTER SCHOOLS OF EACH OF THE
DISTRICTS WHETHER IT'S IMPORTANT
BILL. OR THE ONE AND.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
NOW THE CURRENT FACILITY IN
OAKLAND AS SOON. IS IS THE IS
THAT THAT THAT'S WAS THE CHARTER
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND THAT'S GREAT
OF THE WHOLE SCHOOL IS MILITARY.
OF ALL SCHOOLS METRICS TO AND SO
ARE YOU SEEKING TO CREATE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THE WHOLE SCHOOL
MILITARY SCHOOLS. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS THAT IT.
SO IT IS ON THIS IS A VERY
UNUSUAL REQUEST FOR US TO GET
INVOLVED IN CHARTER SCHOOL
FUNDING OR CHARTER SCHOOL.
CREATION OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
BECAUSE NOT ONLY THEIR THEIR
THEIR EXISTENCE IS DRIVEN BY ABA
AND THE RESOURCES THAT COME WITH
IT AS WELL AS SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS. AND APPROVAL BY THE
SCHOOL BOARD FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
ALL THAT WILL HAPPEN THESE WILL
THESE WILL BE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THAT ARE FORMED AND FUNDED THREE
EIGHTY A EIGHTY A WILL BE
SPONSORED BY THE.
.
BY THE SCHOOL.
THE DISTRICTS IN WHICH THEY
RESIDE THEY WILL HAVE A I'M
SCHOOL BOARD JUST LIKE A CHARTER
SCHOOL WITH THE CIVILIAN
SUPERINTENDENT. AND ALL OF THEIR
FUNDING MODELS WILL BE A PRE
MUCH IDENTICAL TO ANY OTHER
CHARTER SCHOOL IN THE STATE WITH
THE EXCEPTION. OF THE MILITARY
COMPONENT THE STATE FUNDS THAT
ENABLES THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO COME AND TO
PROVIDE THAT.
THOSE EXTRA PERSONNEL TO TEACH
THE LEADERS OF CHARACTER CLASS
TO HELP IMPROVE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
OKAY NOW WHO PUT WHO DOES THAT
WITH THE OPEN CHARTER SCHOOL AYE
SO MAY HAVE FOLKS TO COME IN
FROM THE MILITARY WE DO WE HAVE.
WE HAVE SIXTEEN PERSONNEL. ON
THAT ARE CURRENTLY WORKING THERE
ARE FULL TIME STATE ACTIVE DUTY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD AND AIR NATIONAL
GUARD. THAT WORKS.
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL SO WE
HAVE A COMMANDANT THAT'S
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBER BUT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SCHOOL THE
TWO PRINCIPALS AT THE SCHOOL.
AND.
ALL OF THE TEACHERS ARE
CIVILIANS THAT ARE EMPLOYEES OF
THAT CHARTER.
HE COMES FROM FINANCE BELIAU US
THE U. PERCHED READY TO GO.
BUT WE RECOMMEND.
THE LET'S SAY TO REJECT. THIS
PROPOSAL.
FOR THE MULTI DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT THESE PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL ACADEMY AS A PERSONAL
PORTABLE. OF BECAUSE AS WITH THE
CADET CORPS THE MILITARY CAN
MEANWHILE IS
UNCERTAIN TO PRODUCE
SIGNIFICANTLY. BENEFICIAL
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES OVERALL
RELATIVE TO OTHER AVAILABLE FROM
INVESTMENTS AND IT IS THEREFORE
CLEAR WHAT'S PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE.
SPECIAL TREATMENT FROM THE STATE
COMPARED TO OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED THROUGH.
HEALTHY FF UP FOR THE EXIT
MISTRESS OF THE RATIONALE FOR
THE PROPOSAL IS TO REPLICATE THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOME RESULTS FROM
THE OAKLAND MILITARY INSTITUTE.
HOWEVER DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THE SO SOME WITH
MIXED RESULTS IN THIS REGARD FOR
EXAMPLE WHILE.
ARE THE OAKLAND INSTITUTE DOES
NOT PERFORM THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SOME
MEASURES.
THERE'S A TENDENCY GRADUATION
RATES IN OTHER AREAS SUCH AS
ENGLISH AND MATH SCORES AND
SUSPENSE RATES ARE THE INSTITUTE
IS EITHER ON PAR WITH A DISTRICT
AS A WHOLE OR IN SOME CASES DOES
WORSE DESPITE.
SIMILAR STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS TO
THE DISTRICT.
ARE WE FOR THE FIND THAT.
THE LCF AMP MODEL.
DOES ALLOW PERSON PORTABLE TO
DIRECTLY FROM THESE ACADEMIES AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED.
THE MILE DID LIVE THE STATE
AWAY FROM.
MECHANICAL GOAL FUNDING TO BASE
FOR PEOPLE FUNDING.
AND AT THIS IS IN FACT HOW ALL
OF THE OTHER.
MILITARY THEMED CHARTER ACADEMY
IS OTHER THAN OAKLAND ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDED.
JUST WE WOULD NOTE THAT.
IN ADDITION TO HIGHER BASE.
PER PUPIL FUNDING FOR.
THESE PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICT SINCE THEY HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF IN WHISTLER AND LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THEY ALSO
GETTING A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE.
IN RECENT YEARS FROM.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL ACOSTA TREASON
FUNDING.
FOR. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
OKAY WILL HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS
CAREFULLY IT IT'S A VERY UNUSUAL
REQUEST TO HAVE US.
GET INVOLVED IN AUTHORIZING
CHARTER SCHOOLS I THINK WE.
.
AND THAT'S SUCH A HYDRA KILEY
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE HERE IT THAT
AT THE STATE AS THOSE
RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD BE TO
AUTHORIZE A CHARTER SINCE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ESTABLISHING. WHAT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
ADDITIONAL CHARTER IS A
SOMETHING OF WHAT IS IT?
I MEAN TO THE JUST TWO MORE.
OKAY SO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CREATING TO WHICH ARTIST. OF THE
CURRENT CHARTER FOR THE OAKLAND
WANT IS IS CHARTED THROUGH WHAT
THE SCHOOL BOARD THROUGH ITS
THROUGH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OKAY
ALL THREE OF THESE WOULD BE
LOCAL CHARTERS.
SPONSORED BY THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT SO THEY'RE NOT STATE
LEVEL CHARTERS OKAY.
SO THEY'RE OKAY BUT.
YES.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
I HAVE YEAH HAVE YOU MADE A
REQUEST TO FOR THE CHARTER SO
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO THE SO BOTH OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SEVEN APPROACH THE
MOTOR DEPARTMENT.
AND SAID THAT THEY INTEND TO
FORM CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ADOPT MODEL. AT
OPEN MILITARY INSTITUTE AND THEY
ASKED US TO WORK WITH THEM TO SO
THIS IS THAT WE'RE HEARING THAT
QUARTER BILL THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
THOSE TO. US SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE REQUIRED ARM ARE EXAMINING
CHARTERS
OKAY AND SO AND THEY WANT TO USE
THAT MODEL.
AND THEY WANT US TO FIND.
A PORTION OF IT IS THAT RIGHT.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF REQUEST
THANK YOU ALRIGHT THAT I WILL BE
HELD OPEN THIS WELL. I WOULD
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN.
WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM.
AND ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT I THINK
BECAUSE A NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM
OKAY.
YES.
CALIFORNIA EARLY WARNING
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEMS.
IF YOU GET BEGIN.
SEC.
TOUGHEST OUT ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
ALL INTRODUCED THE EARTHQUAKE
EARLY MORNING PROPOSAL. WHERE
REQUEST DEEMED? FIFTEEN POINT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND.
ONGOING TO COMPLETE THE BUILD
OUT OF THE NECESSARY STATIONS
FOR THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM AND SUPPORT THE EXISTING
POSITIONS.
THIS WILL ALLOW FOR THE INS
INSTALLATION OF THE REMAINING
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
STATIONS OF THE ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN STATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS.
BEING NEEDED STATEWIDE.
THE SYSTEM WILL PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC WITH ADVANCE WARNING WHEN
AN EARTHQUAKE OCCURS WHICH WILL
ALLOW TIME TO PREPARE OR STOCK
CRITIC.
AND STOP CRITICAL FUNCTIONS
SUCH AS SURGERIES AND TRAINS
PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF SHAKING.
IN TWO AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN KELLY HAS RECEIVED A
ONE TIME OF PREPARATION OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND FOUR
POSITIONS TO INVEST.
IN THE INSTALLATION AND UPGRADE
OF THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE EIGHT WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY ONE TIME SAVINGS FROM
GRANT FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE FOUR
POSITIONS.
HOWEVER THE FUNDING IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE AND WE'RE REQUESTING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
POSITIONS AND PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE.
TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILS ON THIS
REQUEST I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
RYAN ARE.
A HAPPY TO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU SHOULD HAVE
ALRIGHT SOUNDS GOOD. OF BEING
GIVEN THIS IS MATHS.
CHAU WILL SEE YELLOW IN THE BLUE
WAS THE DIFFERENCE.
YEAH SO IT'S STARTING WHERE I
LIVE.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO TAKE A GOOD
EDUCATED GUESS THERE BUT
STARTING IN THE UPPER LEFT HAND
CORNER THAT WAS THE.
ONE CALLAWAY ES RECEIVED ITS
FIRST A GENERAL FUND HIGHER MISS
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BUDGET THAT
WAS WHERE WE WERE AT SO WE'RE
ABOUT HALFWAY BUILT OUT ON THAT.
I'M NEEDED SENSOR DENSITY FOR ON
THE STATEWIDE EARTHQUAKE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM IT MOVING DOWN
YOU SEE THE NEXT.
BOX WHICH IS STATED ITS CURRENT
THAT REFLECTS.
WHAT HOW MUCH MORE CAPACITY
WERE ABLE TO ADD WITH THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FUNDS AND IN
THE FUTURE WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING THIS BUDGET? REQUEST
I'M WOULD BASICALLY COMPLETAS
SENSOR BUILT OUT NO SIR I'M
REPRESENTED BY THE YELLOW DOTS
AND I'M SHOWING NON DOING TODAY
AREAS WHICH HAVE LOWER. AND
CENTER DENSITY TODAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
BELIAU.
UP WE RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE.
WITHHOLD ACTION ON THIS
PROPOSAL UPENDING THE RELEASE OF
THE FORTHCOMING BUSINESS PLAN.
FROM THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ORIGINALLY DUE FEBRUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR BUT WHICH HAS
BEEN DELAYED. AYE WITHOUT THE
BUSINESS PLAN.
WE THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IT LACKS KEY INFORMATION
CONCERNING.
THE SYSTEMS COSTS AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL AVAILABLE FUNDING
SOURCES I THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO DETERMINE THE
MERITS OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
REQUEST.
I WE FIND THAT.
.
KEY COST IN FUNDING DETAILS FOR
THE SYSTEM THAT ARE MISSING FROM
THE
PROPOSAL WHICH SHOULD BE
PROVIDED IN THEM OF BUSINESS
PLAN INCLUDES ASKS INFORMATION
AS FIRST.
THE FULL ARRAY OF EQUIPMENT
THEY'LL BE POST OPERATE THE
SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE GOING TO
STAND THAT FROM DOCUMENTS ISSUED
FROM.
PREVIOUS MEETINGS OF THE SYSTEMS
ADVISORY BOARD THAT.
RATHER MADE ALSO BE GPS AND
TELEMETRY NODES THAT NEED TO BE
INSTALLED IN ADDITION TO THE
SENSOR STATIONS.
PROPOSAL WOULD PAY FOR A SECOND
IT'S UNCLEAR. ABOUT WHAT THE
TOTAL ONE TIME AND.
ONGOING COSTS FOR THE SYSTEM
ARE I THIS IS RELATED BOTH TO
OUR COMMENTS ON THE EQUIPMENT AS
WELL AS TO.
THE ONGOING COSTS FOR WHICH WE
HAVE SEEN DIFFERENT UNOFFICIAL
ESTIMATES.
TOLLING IN THE LOW TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS PROPOSAL ONLY REQUEST
SEVENTY FIFTY THOUSAND.
DOLLARS IN ONGOING A COST FOR
PERSONNEL RELATED.
COSTS
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE OTHER
KNOWN.
COSTS SUCH AS END USER
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT AMONG A
FEW OTHERS.
BUT THIRD THERE'S ALSO
UNCERTAINTY OVER THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE MONTREAL
FUND REVENUE SOURCES THAT CAN BE
APPLIED.
TO THE EARLY WARNING SYSTEM
INCLUDING FEDERAL FUNDS.
AS WELL AS HOW.
MUCH OFTEN SUPPORT WILL BE.
REQUIRED TO COVER THE REMAINING
ONGOING COSTS.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE SYSTEM HAS
RECEIVED FUNDS HAS MENTIONED.
FROM DIFFERENT SOURCES IT IN
THE PAST.
AND THAT ARE ONE OF THE GOALS OF
THE BUSINESS PLAN IS TO IDENTIFY
NOT JOURNAL FUND REVENUE SOURCES
FOR THE SYSTEM.
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
NOT COMMITTED TO COVER ALL OF
THE NOT PERSONAL RELATED ON
GOING COSTS.
WITH NIGEL FUND SOURCES.
AND FINALLY WE BELIEVE BY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S SHE SHOULD
PROVIDE LEGISLATURE WITH A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE.
OPERATIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS
THE US GEOLOGICAL SURVEY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE'S STILL UNCERTAINTY IN
THIS REGARD AND I WE KNOW THAT
THE SYSTEMS ADVISORY BOARD HAS
PREVIOUSLY CITED OTHER CLEAR
DELINEATION OF ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AMONG THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF. STRATEGIC.
CLOONEY NEVER COME INTO
QUESTIONS.
ANY.
COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE ANY
OF THOSE IN FAVOR.
ANY POST OKAY FINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL. OBVIOUSLY TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION THANKS
FOR THE. SOMEWHAT HELPFUL WITH
THOSE
AND I HOPE WE WILL GET THE
ANSWERS TO SOME OF THE LA JOH
COMMENTS FROM BETWEEN NOW AND
THE TIME WITH TO MAKE FUNDING
DECISIONS.
I LAST ITEM FOR THE DAY IS
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY SUSTAIN SUSTAINMENT
.
OKAY YEAH SO WHERE KRISTEN
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
SIX POSITIONS AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO NEXT GEN NINE ONE
ONE.
THE FIGHTER COSTS FOR THIS
PROJECT WILL BE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND. THIS WOMAN'S AND I ONE ONE
SYSTEM FROM AN ANALOG SYSTEM TO
A DIGITAL SYSTEM WHICH IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
NEW TECH. LOGICAL DEMANDS SUCH
AS DATA SHARING THEM LOCATION
ACCURACY. THAT PROVIDE BETTER
COVERAGE WITH WHEN OUTAGES FOR
EVACUATIONS OCCUR. AND ALLOW FOR
INTEGRATION WITH THE FIRST
RESPONDER NETWORK AUTHORITY
WHICH IS MORE COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS FOR SNACK.
TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILS ON THIS
REQUEST I HAVE WITH ME TODAY.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF LOGISTICS
MANAGEMENT MITCH.
MEG. AND I CAN'T GET YOUR LAST
NAME RIGHT INSIDE OF.
THANK YOU ADMITS MEDICAID WHICH.
NICE TO BE HERE THANK CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SUFFER TIME TODAY.
I I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT.
THIS IS A CRITICAL A PIECE FOR
US.
THESE.
THIS AUTHORITY THE SPENDING
AUTHORITY INCREASE FOR US.
FOR THE USE OF CERTAIN OF FUNDS
IN THE POSITIONS.
WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE FOR FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE
ONE.
OKAY WE REALIZE THAT ON THERE
SOME CONCERNS ON.
WHERE THE STATUS OF CERTAIN IS
AND AND SOME THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING THERE?
BUT WITH OUT THIS AUTHORITY IN
THE POSITIONS WE CAN'T MOVE
FORWARD NEXT GENERATION I WON
ONE. AND IT'S BEEN CRITICAL.
IT YOU KNOW THIS LAST YEAR.
WE HAD.
NUMEROUS PRESIDENTIAL OF
DISASTERS.
AND IT HIGHLIGHTED THE
NECESSITY OF A.
YOU KNOW VERY EFFICIENT AND
RELIABLE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO IF WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE
RESILIENCY FOR GONNA IMPROVE
REDUNDANCY INTO FOR GUN IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE PROGRAM FOR US.
.
AND OF CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO
LEAD THE NATIONAL.
ARCHITECTURE ON NINE ONE ONE
FOR ME TO BE PART OF THAT DESIGN
PART OF THE STANDARDS IN MAKING
THAT FOR WE HAVE TO BE OUT
FRONT.
OF FROM RIGHT NOW WERE ON THE
CUSP OF MOVING FORWARD WE'VE
DONE THE PLANNING WOULD ON THE
STAFFING WOULD ON THE PILOTS.
BUT WE NEED THESE POSITIONS AND
THEN ULTIMATELY EVER INDEED THE
SPELLING CHRIS SPENDING
AUTHORITY WITHIN THE SECOND
ACCOUNT. TO MAKE THIS A REALITY
OF FOR US.
.
THE OTHER PIECE TO THIS IS THAT
THERE IS A POTENTIAL FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING TO COME DOWN TO ASSIST
US WITH NEXT GENERATION I WON
ONE. BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXECUTE IT. AND SO
WITHOUT HAVING.
THE AUTHORITY AND THE POSITIONS.
IF WE GOT THE MONEY WE WOULD
NECESSARILY BE ABLE TO TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH THAT FEDERAL.
MODEL NOW WE HAVEN'T GOT A
GUARANTEE WHEN THAT MONEY'S
GOING TO COME OR IF IT'S GOING
TO COME. BUT WE KNOW THE
DISCUSSIONS TAKING PLACE AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL NOW AND THERE'S.
INCREASED INTEREST ON MOVING
MONEY TO THE STATES FOR NEXT
GENERATION I WON BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE. HOW IMPORTANT IS AS
WELL?
A WE HAD TWENTY MILLION CALLS
LAST YEAR IN THE NINE ONE
SYSTEM.
AND AND WE SEE NO REASON FOR
THAT TO DECREASE AT ALL AND IN
FACT WILL LIKELY INCREASE TO IT.
AND WE'RE SEEING SOME FASTENING
DYNAMICS AS WE'RE MOVING TO
TEXAS NINE ONE ONE IN OTHER
AREAS FOR IT.
SO. WELL WITH THAT I HAVE
BUDGET CURRIER WHO'S MY NINE ONE
BRANCH MANAGER WITH ME AND HE'S
GOT TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF OF QUICK.
UPDATES ON HOW OUR TECHNOLOGIES
CONNECT
SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT.
WE HAVE SOME SLIDES OF FOR THE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S BUDGE CAREER ON THE
NINE ONE BRANCH MANAGERS MITCH
SAID SO IN FRONT OF YOU HAVE
THIS GRAPHIC HERE CONNECTING THE
TECHNOLOGY. WE KNOW THE SPACE
IS.
A CONFUSING AND.
DYNAMIC AND SO THIS GRAPHIC IS
TO HELP UNDERSTAND HOW THESE
CONNECT THESE TECHNOLOGIES
CONNECT ONE WITH ANOTHER. CC
NEXT GEN NOT NINE ONE IS ON THIS
GRAPHIC AND THAT'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON WHEN YOU NEED HELP
AND YOU HAVE THESE VARIOUS
DEVICES. NEXT GEN I'M ONE IS HOW
YOU GET THAT INFORMATION INVOICE
INTO THE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINT. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
COORDINATE THE RESPONSE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE HELP YOU NEED
ARRIVES
SO NEXT GEN I'M ONE IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONCE IT ARRIVES
AT THAT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT THEY'RE USING
LAND MOBILE RADIO TO COORDINATE.
DISPATCH OPERATIONS WITH THOSE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS IN THE
FIELD AND THEN THE FIRST MATTER
BROADBAND SERVICES IS HOW THAT
DATA IS GETTING FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS. OUT TO
THE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
AND THEN ACROSS THE BOTTOM OF
THE GRAPHIC WAS SHOWN THIS IS A
DIFFERENT PATH BECAUSE IT IS.
AND THIS IS THE WAY THAT ALERTS
AND WARNINGS WOULD WOULD BE
UPSET FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT OF THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY THAT SITE AUTHORIZED
TO SEND THAT ALERT WARNING. BACK
OUT TO THE TO THOSE THAT THAT
NEED TO RECEIVE THOSE WARNINGS.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT I'VE WITH
INFORMATION FLOW HERE NEXT
JANICE IS CRITICAL TO BRING THIS
DATA INTO THE NINE ONE.
PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS.
THE NEXT GRAPHIC JUST REALLY
KIND HIGHLIGHTS THAT IMPORTANCE.
.
NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE IS
BRINGING IN THOSE RICH DATA
SOURCES WHETHER IT'S TEXTER
VIDEO OR ON OTHER.
APPLICATION DATA THAT MIGHT BE
RUNNING AS WELL AS VOICE INTO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINT AND HAS THIS CONNECTION
PIECE TO FIRST MATTER BROADBAND
SERVICES SO THAT DATA CAN BE
SENT. OUT TO THE FIELD.
AND SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS TRANSITION
TO NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE.
IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT IF WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
NOW NEXT GEN I'M ONE HAS SEVERAL
ADVANTAGES OVER OUR CURRENT
NETWORK. PROBABLY THE BEST
EXAMPLE I CAN GIVE IS DURING THE
ORVILLE DAM INCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED.
EARLIER BUT LET'S SAY I WAS
RUNNING A PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT AND AND YOU
RUNNING ONE WE HAD AN AGREEMENT
AND A AND A HARD CONNECTION
BETWEEN US.
THE ONE I EVACUATE I CAN SEND MY
CALLS TO YOU AND VICE VERSA.
THAT WORKS REALLY WELL INTO WE
BOTH HAVE TO EVACUATE WHICH IS
WHAT HAPPENED IN OR FULL.
NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE IS IS A
NETWORK THAT INTERCONNECTS ALL
THESE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINTS OF THESE CALLS COULD
LITERALLY BE ANSWERED ANYWHERE.
AND HAS A NUMBER OF OTHER
ADVANTAGES AS WELL INCREASED
DIVE FASTER CALL DELIVERY WERE
POSITION BETTER FOR INCREASED
THOUGH CASH LOCATION ACCURACY.
AT SOME OF THE DATA RICH
FEATURES THAT COLUMN IN WHAT YOU
EXPECT TODAY AB TO BE ABLE TO
SEND INTO A PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS. NEXT GEN
POSITIONS US FOR THAT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE WE FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT.
OMINOUS MITCH SAIDWE WE DO HAVE
A. LITTLE OVER TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION CALLS THAT WE BRING IN.
WILL.
WE'RE PREPARED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
A REVENUE SOURCE AND AND AND
THE SET THE FUND AND HOW IT'S
BEEN DECLINING. A REALLY THAT'S
PRIMARILY DO SO THAT'S THIS NEXT
GRAPH THAT YOU SEE HERE. ON THAT
THE CHARTS.
AS IT GOES DOWN.
RIGHT NOW OUR FUNDING MODEL IS
BASED ON INTEREST STATE VOICE IT
WAS A FANTASTIC MODEL BEFORE THE
INVENTION OF SMARTPHONES.
BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE
SMARTPHONES A MAJORITY OF OF
YOUR WIRELESS PHONE BILL GOES
TOWARD DATA AND NOT VOICE
AND SO THAT REVENUE. IT IS NOT
SOMETHING WE'RE COLLECTING
AGAINST THE D. DATA REVENUE
PORTION OF YOUR WIRELESS BILL.
THAT'S CONTRIBUTED TO THIS RED
LINE GOING DOWN ABOUT SIX
PERCENT PER YEAR AND WE CONTINUE
TO SEE THAT TREND IT'S IT'S
CONTINUING TO DROP ABOUT SIX
PERCENT PER YEAR. SO WE KNOW WE
NEED IT.
FUNDING MODEL TO SUPPORT THIS
WHAT WE HAVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE INTRODUCED
TO CORRECT THE FUNDING MODEL SO
THAT ONCE WE GET THE
APPROPRIATIONS TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES TO BUILD OUT NEXT AND
I AM ONE. WE'VE PROPOSED A
STABLE FUNDING MODEL TO TAKE A
STAND TO THE NEXT
TEN TWENTY YEARS TO MAKE SURE
THAT NEXT GEN I'M ONE AND AND
THEN I WANT SYSTEM IS SUSTAIN.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS OR
FINANCE BELIAU.
WELL OKAY READ MOST AGREE ANY
ANY.
COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
THOSE IN FAVOR OF.
OKAY.
PRESSES YOU GIVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AGENCY THAT YOU REPRESENT
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAYS STEVE
CARLTON GIPSON CTIA THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION
WANTED A. TO THANK OF COMMITTEE
STAFF WE HAVE SENT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WITH WE'VE OF
WORKING VERY CLOSELY.
AS SAID MR CARTER INDICATED
WILL BE.
IN THE COURSE OF MODIFYING THE
MATTER IN WHICH THAT THE NIGHT
ON ONE FEE IS.
HAS BEEN TRADITIONALLY
COLLECTED.
THAT WE'RE KIND OF A BIG DEAL
FOR THE CELL PHONE INDUSTRY
HAVING DONE SO AND AND.
FOR SO MANY YEARS.
WE THINK WE'RE VERY VERY VERY
CLOSE. TO AGREEMENT ON.
ON PRETTY MUCH ALL ASPECTS OF.
OF WHAT THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE.
MET BUT MISS KIM THE OTHER DAY.
AND AND KIND OF WENT THROUGH
THAT SO WE. WOULD URGE THE
MEASURE DEBATE TO BE.
TO ME BILL FORWARD AND AGAIN
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS.
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING WE
THINK VERY HIGHLY OF SELF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE PROPOSAL
AND THIS ITEM TO WILL BE HELD
OVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF A
RELIGIOUS ELEMENTS IF YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION YOU
WANT TO SHARE WITH US MAKE SURE
YOU SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
A STAFF.
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID WE ARE
NOW IN THE CONCLUSION OF OUR
MEETING A SOMEONE HAS SOMETHING
ELSE TO OFFER.
WE ARE ADJOURNED UNTIL I GUESS
NEXT WEEK WHEN WE MEET AGAIN
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
COMING. THINK